[Music]
trish is out here looking like a troll
doll happy game pride month i'm so
excited i legitimately
queer all of the above everything all
the all the letters all the letters the
alphabet army i love it i actually don't
know the army alphabet army is that what
they call themselves i hope it's not
derogatory i think it's okay to say i
hear my i hear all my friends say it so
i think it's like okay i don't know but
i actually don't really know why like
the revolutionaries behind gay pride i
just like that we get to wear rainbows
and celebrate like liking everything and
everyone my gay pride nails taste the
rainbow i've got the bisexual flag over
here the non-binary both genders the
cross genders oh
very exciting you're saying the cause
whatever the dress up great i don't
really get it right the cause is like
yay we're gay or like it's okay to be
i'm not really sure but i like i like
celebrating being gay well hold on hold
on a gay birthday you know gabe well
okay yeah keep going keep going you're
throwing off your birthday i feel like
it's more important talk about your news
i mean you don't literally have a baby
well you don't understand the gay pride
well because gay being gay has been like
a major
social issue right i get that but who's
the revolutionary behind starting gay
pride month like who are we celebrating
who are the people the gay people
especially the peop freddie mercury yeah
he's included
i believe gay pride month is in june
because of the stonewall riots in new
york
oh what is that dan educate us uh i mean
i'm far from an expert but in the i want
to say 70s maybe 60s on this show you're
the expert
wow uh yeah there was um a breakout of
violence uh because there were uh
a lot of discrimination in uh police
brutality towards
gay people and um
i think stonewall was a i want to say it
was a gay club or bar or something and
there was a raid on it by the police and
it turned into a riot and like people
fought back and stuff and yeah i mean
there was
well we selling we've come a long way by
2021. we support so i think gay pride is
very important because you know
there's still a lot of like people in
this country that just hate gay people
for religious reasons or i think it's
mostly religious reasons yes
and it's like
dude you gotta you gotta get with the
times bro i think jesus would be down
with the gays he created them you know
like he's down he's down with us you
know he's like i created them or god
that's what i just don't get it's like
why would god create it's like you have
this idea of original sin but
is gay being gay in original sin because
that's why no no there's a difference
but it's like why would you create this
person just to condemn them yeah that's
not a real thing oh you know what they
think the religious people they think
being gay is a choice they're like oh
you just like bo you're choosing just
the like dude oh yeah we got a boycott
chick-fil-a this month because they're
that people they support anti-gay that's
true
i think they stopped it after they got
something they did you know what i could
be wrong though after this we're going
to west hollywood to my favorite
restaurant pomp i'm going to start west
hollywood because i just feel ready to
come out um bro you are a troll doll i
mean i don't know if troll is the right
one you are the hair i was like holy
[ __ ] bro you need like a huge gem in
your belly button i do i have one but
you can't see it i always have a belly
button ring
i love being we should be troll dolls
you want to dress up that'd be awesome
okay i would like to be dressed as a
troll doll you just worry we just have
to get the jewels on our belly and the
hair sticking up that'd be cute i think
that'd be super fun and you need you
probably need some kind of prosthetic if
you want to look really good because
they have like huge big ears yeah big
ears i mean i kind of look like a troll
doll anyways but anyways happy gay pride
month we support everyone at stonewall
we support the gays west hollywood
there's way there's still way too much
uh homophobia in the world i do honestly
it's like so pathetic at this point to
to be still clinging to homophobia like
bro how is it your business if dudes
want to touch tips like that's just not
your concern oh my god
yeah i get where you're going i get the
sentiment i mean what what is it it's
like if dudes if their dicks touched
then all of a sudden like the world ends
i mean i just don't get it i think it's
like
honestly homophobic people are usually
like gay themselves they're just like
not comfortable because everyone's like
on the spectrum a little bit right like
they always like no matter what even if
it's not the gay thing whatever there's
always like a little and i think they're
like so i think they're like closeted
homosexuals
i think there's some of that i think um
well when you listen to what they say
they go oh
you are [ __ ] that is that designer
they're really cute right they're new
for pride month i like it thanks okay
but like think about what they're saying
they saying being gay is a choice and
you're just choosing because to them
they're like ooh
sleeping with the same sex is so
appetizing but you have to resist that
it's like that's the gayest thing when
they go
no like uh this is what the
conversion and stuff
it's a choice and you have to choose to
be straight it's like dude you're so gay
if you believe that because they're
saying i want to sleep with the same sex
i just can't because it's against god
that's so crazy i vibe with gays more
than straight people i don't know if i
can say that but i don't i vibe with the
gays more than like i prefer gay people
over straight people is that like
hateful i don't know i feel like a
little offended
do you think so i don't know i don't
feel fenna but i like gays better than
straight people i just i do find it kind
of an odd statement though just like i i
prefer gay oh yeah you don't like when i
say i like somebody i like a group of
people
yeah because it's like fetishizing them
no if i say i love the gays watch the
gays in the comments they all know
they'll be like yes they left when i
said that on the bus tour they're like
trisha performing for the gays
i would love it i'm not gonna i i don't
what do i know i can't speak i would
love if people would say like i'm for
the tricia's pedestal in the world and
i'm like yes thank you
oh so you're what does that mean like i
think
like
calling out a group of people gays
jewish trisha's i would be so excited
what is a trisha well i'm just saying
i'm that group so if someone's like i'm
doing this for the trisha's i'd be like
thank you i wouldn't be like oh my god
what is it
here's an example of fat chicks like
people who are like i love fat girls i'm
not like oh my god don't fetishize me
i'm like thank you like fat bottom girls
or micah has one call like that okay let
me ask you this girl if you go you go
listen my preference is fat chicks then
people go okay god bless
call fat checks but then what if you go
my preference is asian women that seems
weird so why can you like fat chicks but
not asian women i guess it depends who
you're talking to like i don't know i
mean someone's like hey i love asian
chicks i mean maybe people find that
offensive but i'm sure there's some
people be like thank you like yeah i
don't know i think it depends on who
you're talking to i think you not that
it's a bad thing maybe most of the world
would get like offended by me like i
love like jews or whatever but moses
thinks it's cool like i'm ready to
convert he's like that's cool like if i
say i love jewish men like they're like
oh okay then i'm your type they know for
sure that you know what i mean so
someone's like i love a fat girl i'm
like oh well then i'm definitely your
type i don't think of it jewish man
i've always had yeah what's your what's
your take on that dan
me or like i like fat chicks
versus i like asians or jews or black
dudes
like is that is there is that all okay
or what do we think about about like
like you said it is like fetishizing a
group a little bit but i mean that is
not no i'd strong i don't know okay how
about that i don't know how about this
okay hold on when girls go i only date
jews i didn't say that though all my
jewish all my boyfriends have been
jewish and they love when i'm like oh my
god like i love that like i used to
always call myself like a shiksa like i
love like they also they got into it you
know what i mean like have you ever been
with a guy who wasn't circumcised who
what's that mean they have the skin yeah
yeah over in europe and stuff they're
all they all have this what's your take
on that um i don't want to shame
anybody's body but like for me i just
didn't know you were supposed to pull it
down so i was like sucking it with the
skin up but i guess you're supposed to
pull it out it was so confusing so i was
a little traumatized by my experience
with it but i guess if you remember to
pull that [ __ ] down i mean i guess it's
fine it's just like a regular penis yeah
yeah it's so it's i don't know
right yeah but
you can't say like you know what i mean
that's like that's a little body shaming
because you can't help i didn't say
anything you said it nobody like you're
asking me i'm like i can't say oh i
don't know you can have exactly so you
can have a preference on circumcision
but you can have a preference on an
entire [ __ ] ethnicity of people don't
have a preference i don't know maybe i
know what you're saying because race is
different than wait i just had a whole
thing on tick talk about this about like
obviously
if you like jewish dudes you better like
their [ __ ] circumcised dicks yeah of
course i love that's like one of my
favorite things about jewish people
but every guy that's like hardcore
jewish does not have a problem with
moving like i love jew men like they're
like thank you like they do men jewish
jewish men i just said i love jew men
that's anyways it's how you take it and
i know you can't say jumin right jew men
yeah jewish men yes yes thank you i
corrected myself anyways a happy pride
month was there a jewish month is there
like jewish remembrance month i think
there is there's a holocaust remembrance
from us when is that the rest of the
year is just [ __ ] jews though no oh
literally me though
right that's you that's your that's your
mantra happy um congratulations i felt
like i should've broken okay so we have
some stuff to talk about i have a
okay sorry it's not all about me you're
having a baby like literally a baby
that's so exciting
yeah you should have brought me i know
you should have brought me something
let's be honest we had you know there
were so many guests we have a lot of
gifts coming for theater they might have
been here yeah no oh but you could have
do you want my diet coke
i don't want no i don't want your diet
coke we have mcdonald's before this so
i'm energetic i'm ready okay so you want
to know what first of all i want i guess
i want to say oh we didn't speak our
sponsors quip stamps credit karma nah
nah nah love you love you wow
love it um
i exercised this morning i'm starting to
do
once every every morning
at 10 a.m for an hour every weekday wow
you guys started today today was my
first day or for the every day every
[ __ ] week because i'm just like i'm
like you know what i've done this i've
been doing this for like a month and a
half two months twice a week i can do
this i'm just gonna i'm just gonna i'm
looking at the man in the mirror you
know michael jackson was talking about
stopping touching kids in that song
think about it think that think about it
didn't even write that song did he
he didn't i don't know
i don't think he did but think about it
he go he's going i'm looking at the man
in the mirror oh
i'm asking him to change his ways he's
talking about him touching his kids
he's like i got to stop
touching kids because this is oh well
maybe he did i don't know did he write
it i don't know he
is not credited as a songwriter
because that was like the only song he
did it right i remember that's why i was
like i have got to stop touching kids oh
i've got people we're going to take that
out of context
michael jackson but anyway yeah so this
is me feel better already well so i was
just going to say about the exercises
i'm not sure if it's going to make me
feel tired because i feel like kind of
tired right really
they always say you get energy when i
don't know i don't work out that's what
people say but i don't [ __ ] feel that
way like i ask eli she exercises in the
morning and i go do you feel tired
and she goes no i feel great and i'm
like sitting here like droopy eyed i
think cause you're like starting out
you're just starting the journey i don't
know
i don't work now i have no idea but i'm
doing it i don't give a [ __ ] wow you
look good no when you guys went in for
the hug on friday's episode i was like
oh my god skinny like your arms were so
skinny from the side my arms when i
hugged someone looks like a ham hock so
i was like
a what a ham hock i don't know what that
is oh a ham hock a ham hock is that
something a ham chunk i don't know a ham
chunk i don't know something with him
like a tomahawk steak
are that sponsored i'm gonna throw your
arm on the grill girl looking succulent
it would be good i have no muscle look
at that i have zero muscle i never had a
muscle it's just fat
i can't make a muscle it's so sad
anyways you could probably punch pretty
good hit pretty hard so anyway that's
something that's going on in my life of
course and then the other thing is that
elas
is so exciting uh that was a good title
too we're pregnant
we changed it because why
we didn't know for sure and then live on
the show ela finally got the call from
the doctor well i just i assumed he was
pregnant because for so many reasons
right right we're doing the fertility
thing she was late on her period and
then she was getting like faint second
pink lines on the pregnancy
and and then like we looked i was like
that's pregnant dude and she did it like
four times and it was faint every time
and so on but on the box it said it was
inconclusive
oh
it said just take it again but it kept
being faint second line i was like dude
you're [ __ ] pregnant bro why don't
you get the pregnant not pregnant
that seems easy the doctor said to use
the strips she said they're more
accurate really yeah oh [ __ ] but um so
you found out on the show so on the show
because so that morning either went for
a blood test
and then they're like we'll call you in
the afternoon so we're on the show
and around you know towards the end of
the show we got a text and the doctor
said to eli you're super pregnant twist
well
i think she was just referring to like
the hormones in her blood
but because of the treatment we've been
doing because
there's a chance that there's gonna be
more than one and then they can split
off so there can be twins in there and
then they can split off it before don't
say that why you don't want four kids i
don't know why not that'd be everything
can i have one
oh like a birkin yeah i'll take one and
then you guys can it's a nice accessory
i just that's so exciting that's oh my
god so yeah i'm i'm honestly
very happy ah maybe that's why you're in
a good mood you were in such a day i was
like oh he's like beaming you have the
pregnancy glow oh i think it's because i
exercise because i like i was sweating
and i just took a shower usually i'm all
grimy i come here come here yeah yeah
you did look fresh you look teddy fresh
thank you um are you gonna name the baby
something with teddy feet are your names
no no no no no no no no fresh is a good
name oh if we have twin girls i'm gonna
need them peace and love
oh that's cute no i'm not like love like
the guy that works for you can name it
after him that's cute
no i'm not gonna name it what would you
name name your babies i can't tell you
can i tell oh no
oh i can't say it's not just me it's
everyone here oh can i say the names
we're thinking about
yeah no i see that's why i don't want to
say mine said what if people copy us
that's true well it's not like a secret
name people can name it
no
jeremiah jeremiah would be good it would
or how about like
uh
edo
edo what country is this israel oh
yeah you know it's israeli name
no i've had people copy my baby name the
one i put out just bears yeah they know
where you're coming from
no they people don't care it's a name
everybody can name their baby whatever
they want but you think it's a boy
everyone thinks it's a girl i personally
don't think the boy i think it's a boy i
i i listen i'm happy with whatever i get
but you want a girl i'll just even it
out ela wants a girl yeah yeah
i would love to have a girl but i'm not
like i don't want to put that i just i'm
happy for anything right right
twins maybe boy and girl
ethan junior yeah and the girl ethan and
gila ela what ethan and eli junior yeah
that's cute i love that that's so cute i
don't like the junior names because it's
like let this kid have his own life why
does he gotta live in your shadow i love
the junior names moses won't let me name
our son moses he's like no i'm moses
yeah
he's moses you want your kid to have
their own identity why is he gonna be
moses jr i like moses i like calling my
son junior though i think it's cute do
you do a theater junior no but i like i
and the idea of it is cute we got lots
of presents coming for theater they're
really cool i think they won't be here
until tomorrow though when's his actual
birthday his actual birthday is on
saturday i think on the on the 4th of
june all right well we got some presents
but you guys are coming over right on
the weekend well i thought it was this
past weekend is this upcoming weekend
yeah this upcoming weekend is his actual
birthday party that was just because my
brother was involved well we didn't know
that either we would have come and i was
like oh well it's just my brother it was
just my brother and his girlfriend oh
but i love i love when there's like more
like plus ones to the family when they
bring like a girlfriend because when i
was just by myself it was like weird but
i was like more plus ones i don't feel
like i'm part of like your family you
know what i mean right but anyways we
would have come we didn't know also the
guy took so long doing my nails it was
like nine hours that day so it was my
fault honestly
yeah it was like a lot so it was there
was someone working on our walls too
were you thinking like um [ __ ] these
gays
you're like these nails are taking too
long oh no no i'm out on this project so
there's an actual sorry that was a joke
you know wait there's a birthday party
this weekend yeah we're coming yeah we
have lots of girls
don't worry i got the guests taking care
of this yeah i was like i'm gonna pick
it out i got him i'm like we made him a
tractor cake we got a custom-made so
it's like a big
wait you had a saturday oh we had two
cakes one was ice cream because he
wanted ice cream oh my god and they had
little tractor toys which he loves on
top and the top of the of the cake was
like ground-up oreos so it looks like
gravel like dirt yeah and he was playing
on the cake with his tractors that
sounds so good this weekend we're making
a tractor cake like a 3d tractor
wow is he gonna take a picture do you
let him dig his hand in there like
little kids do i love that i don't you
should let him grab it i don't think he
does that oh he's super light yeah he's
too polite oh my gosh that's so exciting
wait are you gonna eat like now that he
looks pregnant are you gonna like eat
with her that's one of the reasons why i
wanted to start exercising first you're
like i gotta eat i am not gonna get even
fatter now that he was pregnant it just
happened she's been already like super
like way hungrier than usual yeah which
is great baby growing in there you gotta
eat i'm afraid she might i think the the
way she's eating though she's probably
got a double twin i don't know ooh then
you should celebrate with a double
double from in and out
every day every day
do you think you have twins
she says she's worried that she might
have oh god i'm worried for her that
seems like a lot
i'd be so scared how do you do that
because i've seen how one baby came out
of her two was just unbelievably i was
like either you're gonna have
quadruplets i was just talking most
about this i think i'd have a c-section
i think i want to do a c-section did you
have a c-section
really oh i don't know if i could do
that oh
well it yeah i mean listen
it's hard work i keep making myself
think i'm pregnant i keep thinking
thinking i'm sick i'm like i'm sick and
then i was like maybe you're pregnant
i'm like no i'm never going nah it's
just the mcdonald's that you eat every
day
hey i'm gonna have a counsel anyways
that's really exciting if you keep
saying i'm making about myself i'm sorry
i keep relating these stories if you
guys are serious about getting pregnant
why don't you go do the fertility well
we have a wedding and i have a dress
that's really tight so i need to like
you already bought the dress yeah the
dress is being made in israel but nah
i'm probably
when is your wedding day i can't say it
oh [ __ ] right
yeah yeah okay so once the wedding's
coming up you guys will do the fertility
stuff maybe after i don't want to be
like sick and like injecting stuff on
there you might get nauseous yeah so
we're just going to wait till actually
okay so after the wedding
you should see our doctor's shoes yeah
for sure like right away as soon as the
one is over she'll yeah she'll hook you
guys up yeah we definitely needed to
because you know we'd be trying but
whatever it's fine but this is so
exciting i always i really do love when
like people get very nice we always stab
and i'm like maybe it's more fertility
because colleen she also texted me when
she was pregnant before she announced it
and i was like oh she's having twins i'm
like oh my god give me some of that
fertility like everyone's getting
pregnant now and i was like oh [ __ ] the
doctor gives it out and the doctor gives
out the fertility that's true well
that's very exciting so yeah i'm gonna
you know it's f it's amazing we're gonna
have a family you have a family i know
but it's like you're gonna have like a
fan right right [ __ ] so i mean it's
fun
i just i love theodore and i love and i
love being a dad and ever since we had
theodore just i love
life
i love kit i just love
my son so much and like i want him to
have siblings and yeah i just feel like
i love kids i love
being a dad oh
yeah you seem so much happier i'm so
excited for you i'm so excited
we were what we were doing friday we
didn't get to see it in time and i
really wanted to watch it everyone was
spoiling it for me on twitter and
they're like ella's pregnant i was like
no
i wanted to watch it oh you want to
watch to hear they linked it i don't
know if you guys watched on friday we'll
watch it again
but
here it is you look you look as good as
look at that oh my god no i don't
know but if i was hugging moses that way
i would like five times your size like
that looks amazing you guys look great
um here it is you do have a very skinny
upper half of your body thank you
shoulders are deceptive fouchy eats
babies from dr falcon it's babies yeah
so ella gets the test
we got what we got what we got what we
got i texted the doctor
do we have confirmation read it rita
verbatim
i texted her i said
i did the blast test today and waiting
to hear the results do you know if it's
ready and she said 3.92 i have no idea
what that number means but she was like
392 exclamation mark you are super
pregnant
yeah i don't know what she meant by that
twin yeah
because it was like you know the last
time we did the fertility treatment yeah
she got her period like early and we're
like oh this is so disappointing yeah
you couldn't have that one hope yeah
like at least once
because she's like we'll know if you're
pregnant in two weeks yeah and then a
week later she got her period we're like
oh this is so sad
especially when you try when you're like
trying so hard yeah and i i don't know
if i said this but like the
the process is brutal like i was
sticking her with a syringe in the
stomach every night you have to hit a
certain spot or just anywhere no just
anywhere in the stomach around the belly
button but like the solution is like for
some whatever reason it's really painful
yeah like you can cramp or what i think
it just stings a lot inside the belly i
don't think i would trust you to poke
anything in my belly i was like no it's
actually a syringe you're so reckless
you're just so like wild anyways just
with your like just you and yeah that
was me i was like okay just close your
eyes here we go
do you get scared i would pass out doing
it to somebody i got better at the first
time was stressful but i got better at
it i mean i've done it like billion
times now oh my god i don't think i
literally don't know if i could do it i
was like ela get re study this because
when i get diabetes you're going to be
doing this to me oh my god
no i did a diabetes joke on tech talking
it did not fly what'd you say
oh oh oh joke about diabetes yeah it was
the almost there tic tac where it's like
almost there i'm almost there so i was
like when i get diabetes
and i took it down they're like you
can't joke about diabetes i'm like oh
wow you can't even joke about diabetes
but we're fat we're like basically
pre-dying you're not bad anymore you
can't be weak
you now you're working out every i mean
good for you don't make me lose no it's
very small it's getting smaller why
don't you show it from the side see it
up and show it because it actually does
look smaller
oh there are people who want to see it
let's see
wow don't stick it out and be stupid
just be normal be normal
wow
okay but you're being stupid boy there
oh boy it looks okay all right
looks good you know the fanny pack that
you wear that looks like a dude's gut
you're making it unattractive passed
away just be normal with it oh boy oh my
god but you're put your hoodie down now
put your hoodie down and show it look at
that what do i need
there it is yeah you are you really are
although now you're not supposed to tell
people if they're losing weight either
because that can also be triggering for
people because they think they have to
keep going and we gotta draw the lines
i'm gonna make fun of diabetes i'm not
making fun of diabetic person i'm not
like ah [ __ ] you got diabetes you just
might get it so you're making yeah i'm
gonna get diabetes at this rate my uncle
had diabetes he just died last year
actually arrested peace i love uncle joe
yeah he was like i was close to him once
for uncle joe oh
he would love that he would love it yeah
he had diabetes his foot seriously he
was having surgery to get his like foot
off and he died during the surgeries
right before coming started yeah it was
like two days into covet it was really
he was like losing his foot to die yeah
he had he already did he couldn't walk
on it it was like um was he a big guy
mm-hmm didn't take care of himself no he
never did and yeah but he we were the
closest he like always support
everything i did my family doesn't know
anything about like what i do my dad or
anything but he's always like supportive
um but yeah it was sad he did lose
weight towards the end of his life but
you know dude a little too late yeah
that's such a funny tic-tac you made
honestly
that's not right the people bullied you
to murder
to bully me to love myself like it's
okay no yeah um
anyways
anyway about uh
this is very exciting look at you how
happy you are yeah i it because we were
on edge all week and yeah so
so one week passed
and we're like okay
and then every day past the week was
like okay no period yeah that's so funny
and then we're like on thursday and then
we hit thursday we're like okay usually
eli knows when she's about to get her
pregnant she gets sore and stuff and
she's like no pr period
pains or anything right and i was like
oh [ __ ] and then so she pees on the
stick and we keep getting these
inconclusives but i was like you're
definitely pregnant dude and she was
like super tired which happens when you
get pregnant yeah so she like knew but
this was her first time finding out here
yeah yeah for sure for our first time
finding for sure i would do one of those
like pregnancy surprises you know when
people like are like make baby carrots
baby back ribs and you have like guests
and the person's like are you pregnant
oh did you do it the first time did she
try and surprise you no we were both
just in it together yeah i mean
i think i'd do like a q a video i'd be
doing a mukbang with moses and i would
just be like
hold a baby or something i don't know
what i would do oh that'd be that would
be fun but i don't think either one
oh yeah like edible babies
eat this baby
i ground up this placenta for you babe
do you think they make like replicas of
placentas to eat like they did with
horse hearts from like game of thrones
you can you can find anything online
really you can find a real placenta
online i know a guy i'll surprise you
too when i get pregnant i'll be on the
podcast i'll find a way to surprise oh
that'd be fun yeah i don't know what i
do like i don't know i don't know
did i just touch your foot no that was
my uh i'm sorry i'm over on your side
but i like i just yeah just knowing
together i like being upfront about the
fertility thing because it is like
something that's not talked about a lot
and it's very stressful you know
when i go to these fertility clinics to
like you know
nut in a cup for for oh wait what
what do you mean wait which part are you
confused about you not in a cup yeah
that was what we were doing we were
doing an insemination so they were
they took my
what's the polite way
what's my plight way to put this my
massive [ __ ] load ew
okay
and um
they they basically turkey based her
with it how do you i think you were
talking about this how do you not know
like they don't switch it
i know it's scary you said that right
like if the doctor puts his in or
something i know it's scary but they
said they only do one at a time and you
watch it are you watching them transfer
it
i would probably like can i watch that
yeah well ela asked them and they're
like we've never been asked to do that
before so i was like i guess i'm just
being super paranoid i don't know they
weigh that like i watch lifetime movies
i'd be like but it's like i do that i
and then and then she comes an hour
later and then they inseminate her like
hums
no she i don't think the doctor's making
her orgasm that'd be weird
so she just goes in
you think the doctor's getting her off
they say when you orgasm you're more
fertile like if if you orgasm at the
same time like you're more fertile that
explains why she's never getting
stupid
um wait so oh my god that's so fast so
anyway my point is when i go there you
didn't do the embryo thing you did no
ivf is like the next level
wow okay
it's more even more invasive you know
so like this is a so i'm happy that this
worked
but when you go to this off these
fertility office uh it's full of young
women
donating eggs no who are trying to get
pregnant oh oh oh yeah cause i guess if
you're young and you're not getting
pregnant there's probably an issue like
you've spent time looking i'm just
saying like a lot of people are getting
pregnant now like like 25 plus and your
fertility goes down so it's hard it's
much it's hard it's much harder to get
pregnant between like 25 and 35 then it
is like 18. yeah so it just people are
like think there's something wrong with
them but it's not it's just people are
having babies
later in life
yeah it is crazy though i do know so
many people that struggle with like
fertility it's like such a cra i didn't
even know that was like a thing to me i
was always praying i want to get
pregnant not knowing it was like so hard
to get pregnant it is crazy but it is
true i'm not saying like safe sex is
really important because when you're
young when you're 18 you get pregnant
like [ __ ] nothing well then there's
some people who like can have like they
have like eight babies it's like crazy
it's like they just be getting pregnant
every like year literally yeah that's
uncommon i feel like but
my brother his kids were like that they
were four three two one they just got
kind of getting pregnant birth rates are
going down across the world and i wonder
if it's just because people are having
babies later in life or just because
we're like drinking plastic and [ __ ]
i think the plastic and [ __ ] because
honestly i'm sure that's why i can't get
pregnant i bet if i like lost weight and
i get healthy and you think it's the
plastic and not the double gonorrhea
i mean it's both it's the combination
for sure it is oh it's so sad well no
you do but my point is you're just like
every other girl your age it's not easy
yeah but like i've always had problems
like always get i always thought i
should get pregnant you gotta go to the
doctor yeah they're gonna help you she's
gonna tell you this doctor's like
amazing we gotta do it quick because
i'll be 34 next year and i'm like i want
like three babies so maybe we'll do all
three at once we do the ivf we'll just
do three embryos
get it out of the way can you do that
three babies inside you at once yeah you
put three embryos in it or like four if
you want like boy how many you want
really a lot of my friends do that like
especially like my gay friends so
they'll put one one they put one embryo
with one person's genetics and the other
embryo with the other person's genetics
oh i see because you're using but you're
using your own eggs not someone else's
right but they're using their own sperm
so one guy will use this from the other
guy and then they'll do it and they'll
get twins
yeah but they're not birthing it you
were birthing the kids yeah i ain't
black and bird twins i look at my i just
didn't know they did that that's
interesting yeah you're sure about that
i'm positive 1000 positive because i had
a couple that did that i wonder what's
the limit how many how many babies can
you do well octo mom had like six or
something at one to eight babies
yeah
maybe we'll see maybe not eight maybe
like three i don't know moses what are
you thinking
two
oh two three kids he won't know
everything you put another one in but a
third one come on
oops
yeah oh my god what
um i thought i wanted two at first two
but now i want more
oh really
yeah i mean maybe one than twins three
is good i grew up with three and i i
think that's really good i had an older
brother and younger sister and i thought
that was like the best yeah i want three
to five now oh my god five lap maybe
three five is a lot four they team up
against each other three they also have
to be a cohesive unit
bro i'm so tired now too because
theodore
started he got his big boy bed now and
so he's been wandering into our bedroom
at 3am every night is it a racecar bed
no it's just it's his crib converted
into a
a uh
a bed you just remove a piece oh and
then he can come and go
because like a few nights ago he jumped
over and scratched into the ground
he actually like escaped did he wait but
i thought it was like a big boy bed so
how did he what is there a gate on it
still no he was in a crib like three
days ago oh so you're like okay we just
had he like bailed on it and he like
walked in he was like all ptsd'd
he had like this big crane like a big
toy crane and he just walked in and his
eyes were like a thousand mile stare
and he just sat in our bed well like
this with this crane and he just goes
teddy got crane teddy got the crane wait
what because the crane was on the floor
i think he was trying to get his toy
crane and he bailed out of his crib and
he walks in just with the crane teddy
got the crane
maybe there was like a ghost talking to
him though like teddy goes there's no
ghost trish but why would he repeat it
like that typically he's crazy to get
crazy no because we would say what
happened you know are you okay
but he referred to him he wasn't tired
he fell out of the out of the he always
refers to himself as teddy really yes
maybe he has an imaginary friend that's
talking to him no said he get crane
wow i've never heard that
we gotta go to break
so i'm like
devastated on sleep lately i can carry
the rest of the show don't worry i got
us
yo yeah okay yeah okay all right word
from our sponsors we'll be back all
right thank you to our sponsors we'll be
right back
thank you to quit for sponsoring us the
electric toothbrush that cleaned your
mouth like nothing else yes show your
black one over here on the on the pink
side yeah woo
[Applause]
so let me tell you about first of all we
do have a big update from quippon who is
winning the competition to raise the
most money for lgbtq plus charities with
the quip smart electric toothbrush but
first we want to tell you about how you
can earn rewards just by brushing your
teeth with these frenemies colored all
pink all black electric toothbrushes
okay first of all let me tell you about
quip because oh yeah you can't see it on
mine yeah um here let me put in from my
face i love quip it's the only
toothbrush i'll use and i'll tell you
why first of all the bristles are so
soft they just they don't damage or
irritate my gums that's huge but the big
pull with the quip it's electric
obviously better
dentist recommended toothbrush with the
electric but when you turn it on you
click this button you hear that
it's so silent it tells you how to get
that perfect brush 30 seconds and then
it vibrates 36
30 seconds 30 seconds so it makes sure
you get that perfect denim dental
recommended brush every [ __ ] time
right right the quip
yes
all you do is pair it with equip app and
you earn points for brushing well so
this rewards you for good brushing
habits by pairing it with the app points
can be redeemed for rewards you want
like a target e gift card or discounts
on things like quipped new refillable
floss pack the quip smart brush comes in
all pink they're like your nana they're
like your nana that really wants to make
sure you take care of yourself exactly
like that and nana okay
you went over how it's done
and it automatically delivers brush
heads every three months for just five
dollars with free shipping worldwide
okay now here's where quip steps up to
be the greatest they've been donating
ten dollars
to each of our charities that we picked
mine is the trevor project what was
yours mine i
i don't know i don't see it in there but
i believe it's trans equality yeah and
so every time someone buys a black one
they donate ten dollars to my charity to
the trevor project and every time
someone buys a pink one they donate ten
dollars transequality.org
and i am up by eight points all pink
teamwork well hold on we've raised okay
i got ahead of ourselves twenty three
thousand dollars i mean that's amazing
that's actually that's so cool yeah
cause these two brothers are cool i mean
i see these like and now they're saying
if you guys are gonna buy the black one
more
because trish is ahead by eight points i
was like i mean i get it the pink one's
cool and you know stanfish or whatever
trisha stands
but if you can if you can buy the black
one and pass her she's up by eight
points they're gonna throw in an
additional five thousand dollars
to both channels wow so you might as
well get the set because who just likes
trisha by herself or ethan by himself
nobody they want us together we're
better together better together so
here's the deal i mean it's true my
channel gets like a hundred thousand
views but when i'm with you i got like
four million you know oh i agree does
kill it on your own but i mean you know
they get way more yeah yeah so we're
back better together
so you might want to get two get the set
get trisha and ethan on your bathroom
counter today sell that too here's what
to do we've got the hook up right now
you can get ten dollars off the quip
smart electric toothbrush with the code
peace and love at get quipped.com one
word peace and love one word at get
quipped.com so who will be the finer
winner with the most money donated
charity just go to
g-e-t-q-u-y-p dot com and use code peace
and love one word to get ten dollars off
the all pink or all black smart brush
and equip will donate ten dollars to
each for each purchase so that's get
quip dot com peace and love
stamps.com are you still going to the
post office still paying full price for
postage well thanks to stamps.com you
don't have to anymore you can mail ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer you can send letters packages
all while paying less a lot less with
discounted rates from usps ups and more
stamps.com is going to save your
business or just you you know if you
don't have a business if you're just a
dude or a girl thousands of hours and
tons of money every year
stamps.com brings the service of the us
post office right to your computer who
goes to the post office anymore this
isn't 2020 this is 20 21. well
especially when there's a freaking
pandemic yeah
stay home and i'm lazy so i'm wondering
i'll be honest like sometimes you go to
the post office and it really depends on
your area but those lines get long
they're long and they don't want to deal
with you and you don't want to deal with
them right you go to sleep it's mutual
you know whether you're small business
sending invoices or just a side hustle
on etsy shipping out orders or just
navigating this hybrid world we live in
stamps.com can handle all of this with
ease it's no wonder over 1 million small
businesses choose stamps.com for their
mailing and shipping simply use your
computer to print out official us
postage 24 7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere anywhere once
your mail is ready you schedule a pickup
or drop it off it's that simple stop
wasting time going to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk and with the promo code frenemies
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts did you know you get a
discount of up to 40 percent off post
office rates and 65
off ups shipping so you're saving it
you're getting a free scale you're
getting the percentage off you're
getting no long-term commissions
four-week free trial sell it get that
special offer with code frenemies when
you go to stamps.com that stamps.com
promo code frenemies yo it's a
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no they already said i mean a
million small businesses people they
can't be wrong with stamps
frenemies never go to the post office
again never go to the post office again
all right thank you to chris karma
who doesn't want instant gratification
if you're looking for satisfaction
there's no need to wait with credit
karma money you could win cash
reimbursements for debit purchases
credit card money is a brand new
checking account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases when
you use your credit karma money debit
card you can win daily insta karma
purchase reimbursements on items up to
five thousand dollars oh you know what's
really cool what usually you get rewards
on credit cards right this is a debit
card but this is a debit card reward yes
and credit card knows what's up just pay
with your debit card and if you win
you'll be notified on the spot and your
instant karma cash will be added back to
your spend account credit card money has
already given away over three million
dollars in instant karma to over 50 000
credit karma members and counting open
your fdic insured spend account for free
there's no minimum balance requirements
no overdraft fees and free withdrawals
from a network of over 50 000 atms
credit karma money progress starts here
right now visit creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma go to go to
creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for free and start
winning instant karma that's
creditkarma.com slash win money you want
to do the fast reading part insta karma
is sponsored by credit card don't
purchase necessary exclusions in terms
of ply c rules banking services provided
by mvp bank incorporated at member fdic
maximum balance and transfer limits
apply
and we're back
hello welcome to freddie thanks for
watching this sponsors
um
yeah just really happy and excited so
thank you for the well wishes i was very
excited for you guys but it was a
chocolate thing like do i text it like
that's just like annoying i feel like
we'll see them cause you wanna see it in
person i don't care okay
congratulations thank you so much you're
welcome thank you can we watch my music
video
um okay chill daddy
on to the next most important thing
so trisha put out a new uh music video
i'm really proud of this okay do you
know the reference of this music video
just by looking at the thumbnail why is
it so dark when i put that it's weird
do you know it can you just write the
thumbnails you know the reference no you
don't know the band no can you guess no
i don't know it one guess
wait really you can't do one guess
your boy george
my chemical romance thank you well i
just that's obvious but i don't i don't
know anything about them well you know
through me okay it's my chemical romance
okay can we watch it short but i'm
really proud of this might be my
favorite one ever
okay i'm gonna give it an honest review
it's not a cover it's an original song
we just did we did an homage to
my chemical romance and a movie called
secret window by stephen kingston okay
do you want an honest review let's pull
even if it's brutal
sure yeah you don't i didn't believe you
when you but i'm not someone who takes
it seriously i don't know those people
like my music's so good like i love
hearing people's opinions because i know
what my music is but i would love to
hear your opinion dead and gone dude you
gotta give it up to my eyesight okay yay
for ethan's eyesight okay here we go
okay
can you crank it down
[Music]
the production value is insane thank you
how much do you spend on this one 100k
remember i told you you were sitting
next to my music video director at my
birthday party he's like don't say how
much it is
like come on we talk shop all the time
yeah yeah that guy's like don't see how
much it is i'm i get paid based on how
much you spend
i was like it's pretty good deal for
these kind of videos i think a hundred
thousand is is pretty good no i am i
think it looks really good so
you know it's worth it
yeah
that's facts set and there is effects in
this you'll see at the end there's some
special
i mean you've got fire ship effects
right here yeah you have to get a fire
truck yeah it's a lot
this is a real [ __ ] and you got like a
wood cabin up in the top yeah wood cabin
was i got to say i love that you're
willing to like invest in this because
it's dope
that's what makes it cool well that you
remember what i was asking like thinking
is awful
[Laughter]
no you know what i was asking like what
your hobby is like what you like put
money you're like i'm like why do you
work so hard you're like i don't know i
just do but it's like i work so hard so
i can make more music videos you know
that's fun that it motivates you even my
apparel like my sad boy like i i really
will just break even if i sell out but
like it's so much fun just to make this
stuff like i don't even really care
about being like you know what i mean
it's just fun anyways i think that this
is i think that's a special quality i
was being in my gerard way dreams right
here this is from famous last words if
you didn't know so is this a cover
original song this is an original song
but the setup is exactly the famous last
word shot got it
all right here we go oh she knew the
video would be more exciting but okay
yeah i apologize
and that's secret window so we're
intercutting with your windows
[Music]
oh you're getting murdered let's let's
be honest you're getting murdered in the
slasher film
[Music]
[Applause]
he's really good the director like
cinematography is really good
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
what did he just gank you oh he's
jumping you out i'll choke out my sister
playing [ __ ] back oh okay because i was
like wow somebody's really got to choke
you for that that's my sister okay yeah
you'll see why they had to be like my
similar body type at the end there's a
twist it's you oh no you guessed it
yeah
well when you said it gotta look like me
yeah i swelled
[Music]
give me a up release
[Music]
do you know the movie secret window with
johnny depp no okay well i'm missing all
the practices
john tutoro he also was in that movie
with him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's
is
i mean that's the secret window plot too
but and you spill it
here comes a special effects shot at the
end
this is the money
[Laughter]
and now you're eating corn i am so what
with the corn shot let's see in a secret
window he eats the corn that he buries
his wife in the corn garden and she made
it all right okay
okay but it's just you eating corn but
that's that's the ending shadow secret
window it's kind of an iconic shot
it's like you gotta show like a girl you
gotta show like a graveyard in the
cornfield or something no you don't know
the corn eating is secret window that's
like iconic okay it makes sense as a
reference but in the scope of the music
video it doesn't make any sense
if i don't get i know but like you're
just eating corn bro that's
it's homage
i didn't know i was just like why are
you eating corn
look at you she's just eating a big ass
bite of corn i don't know all these pop
culture references like i feel like you
grew up in the same era i did yeah
i'll be honest with you i don't know
what happened but like my growing up i
missed everything it was all this stuff
i just can't get over this scene of you
eating corn you're like let's go
that's like that's an iconic shot i
don't know what to tell you but in the
movie
you know he buried his wife
no but if you see that here's johnny
shot people know it's the shining like
people just know signature shots like
that's what but it still has to make
sense in the scope of the story
my chemical romance i think you do a
secret window they don't make sense like
both of those things so i put them yeah
what do you what am i right or am i
wrong
about the corner agree with you because
he always says i'm right on this one go
ahead
if you don't know the reference it does
seem random i i i don't know did you
know the reference i i'm not familiar
enough with secrets well either way it's
funny i love the corn eating oh it's
like a big ass bite of corn to end your
music video oh man i wish you knew the
references i love the comments though
people are always like yes i love when
she mentions gerard like people hype me
up in the comments i knew the reference
to the music video you did yeah okay
halfway there yeah sorry secret window
missed that one that was my that was an
iconic movie it was his first movie
after pirates of the caribbean was
secret window with john tutor
it's really good i i love it
um anyways that's my favorite video i've
ever done that was really good i had so
much fun the production value was crazy
thanks and if you knew the references
like the famous last words video like he
did he did a great job like because we
replicate everything like we own up to
that so let me ask did you film this all
in one session or how many so we did the
merch shoot and the performance the same
day and then we did the cabin the next
day so we usually do back-to-back shoots
so i will say it's a hundred thousand
for everything so for that merch video i
did with the transam and then this so
there you go you know it's
yeah that's more reason right okay yeah
that's very that's very reasonable i
shot one music video at universal
studios for two hundred thousand dollars
and that was like my most they had like
water at universal we had to get like
the universal employees in like it was
oh it was really fun yeah
anyways um also there's still some stuff
left at sadboy2005.com so if you could
put the link to my music video and
sideways on fight.com just for this
anything else
you have ten links in the description i
could have two but whatever you want you
have like 20 pounds at the bottom
i'll put mine at the bottom no i'll put
it at the top i'm just kidding
we still have a few things left we did
still have a lot of stuff like we have
probably like one size of like five
styles left so we did sell out a lot
like thank you so much like i did thank
you guys thank you for that i was really
shocked because you know that was just
like you know my first four way into
like streetwear
looking hey teddy i said boy 2005.com
let's go i'm just really trying to live
out my emo dreams you know what i mean
oh one other thing we skim by memorial
day is there anything you want to say
for our for our uh fallen troops um i i
resp i respect all of our troops i love
people who are in the military no
seriously can you imagine like
the people who just like volunteered
like everyone in our country right now
just volunteers to go
that's crazy
that's amazing i mean i love it i mean
that's amazing but i would be so
freaking scared to join the army unfort
i think that the army you don't like it
i don't like the army i but i i like the
soldiers that's the thing you have to
make a distinction between the soldiers
and the war itself because they don't
choose where to go fight and stuff
they're just trying to defend a lot of
people who enroll in the army are doing
it for the opportunities the army you
know
gives
but like my thing about mor the soldiers
i was thinking about it today it's like
when you fight a war abroad
there's always going to be a war at home
with mental health like you know today
more soldiers die from suicide than in
battle
yeah i didn't know that that's crazy
yeah it's crazy so it's like you got if
you're going to spend a trillion dollars
on missiles and bombs and [ __ ] you got
to spend the money on back home to take
care of the people i think they do that
i know no i know he's not very popular
but piers morgan one celebrity
apprentice and donated his to uh
that the charity that helps soldiers
deal with that kind of stuff i forget
what it's called but yeah i know that is
like a thing but they shouldn't even
they shouldn't rely on charity the
government if you're going to [ __ ]
send them there you better take care of
them when they get back yeah so i i like
yeah i feel like memorial day also
includes people who are like drafted
that didn't even have a choice like
vietnam you know yeah and and those guys
you know
it's amazing they are i know that's it
blows my mind my grandpa uh who's who's
recently passed but he was a world war
ii uh
gunner he controlled the gun on the on
the airplanes in world war ii wait
really and yeah he was he was shot down
a bunch of times and had to parachute
out
my grandpa was too
wow
he doesn't he didn't talk about the war
ever he didn't like talking about it oh
yeah because probably [ __ ]
that i mean that's the worst ptsd the
thing is back then too they didn't this
whole issue of uh
mental health awareness and stuff this
was like
not a tapu yeah and these are all like
macho guys who are very like uh
classical male you know they're like
rugged do it yourself so these guys come
back with like absolute
ptsd and trauma and depression and
anxiety and it's like
it's like yeah the the battle continues
on when you get home did you see the
deer hunter movie yeah i've seen that
that one i watched for the first time
like maybe like a few days you watched
that whole thing yeah well that wasn't
because i saw someone on twitter say
that they're like oh my god and i've
always and i love like i love that
through deer hunter and not schindler's
list
i preferred deer hunter
had some like funny moments you know
christopher walker and like singing in
the bar like you know they had some like
cute moments in it that movie is
horrific but that that's what i was like
whoa you know what i was like watching
it was like that's crazy because like
i'm sure that [ __ ] happened right like
that [ __ ] like
that's garlic
extreme situation but yeah i had like
nightmares just that guy screaming just
like mama you know
um sad this is a sad episode did we just
bring it all down no hey we're giving it
up to our to our best oh yeah yeah shout
out too and you know i think it's
important too because like i generally
these days i'm very anti-war
but it's important to remember that the
war is not the
soldiers
soldiers always deserve
respect and to be taken care of
especially when they get home yeah
i think our government has done a dismal
job taking care of the troops
you know [ __ ] up
did you see biden collabing with
youtubers how come he didn't collab with
you i never get reached out for anything
cool well he was like clapping with no
shay because manny mua like like is
we're cool now but like he was clapping
like manny mua and i was like oh it's so
random biden got the manny clap yeah
that's so
it's so weird right but like you know
biden was collabing with all these
people
i guess i'm controversial i don't know
but you're so hardcore abiding you're
like you're like oh yeah biden is like
yeah
i wouldn't go that far i think so yeah i
mean i call him sloppy joe biden what's
that mean he's sloppy
yeah did you hear anything about the bar
rights and how she looks like a cute
little 12 year old yeah that's like a
lot but joe biden he listen i like i
like him i like sloppy jokes now he's
our president now right
oh no
stop he is not right no not yet still
president no stop which one is but joe
biden's president oh he's vice president
kamala's president
i had a kamala harris jacket today but
it didn't fit did you want to see it
sure um i sent it to the person who
blinked it up for me and it was it was
modeled after combo hairs but it
wouldn't fit me see she had a little
pride jacket do you remember her wearing
that jacket no but it looks nice
okay well anyways
so anyway shout out to the troops wait
you guys are wearing it see that was the
replica i was gonna wear a combo here
i know but it didn't fit me some didn't
work out oh i wanted to also say you
guys frenemies vlog number two is up you
guys should go watch that if you haven't
it's freaking awesome i thought it came
out great i'm very proud of it we
hijacked a hollywood tour bus iconic
hollywood bus and we gave a bunch of
people a tour and we obviously what the
[ __ ] do we know trish actually knows a
lot
i didn't know anything i'm just really
bad at speaking in front of people like
you know
if i'm in front of like people who like
me and like know me not that they didn't
like me but you know what i mean like if
people know me and they're trish fans
like i love it but if people don't i get
so nervous i'm like i'm so cringy well
you did great and the video's really fun
i'm proud of how it came out so if you
haven't seen that friendly's vlog number
two let's [ __ ] go also moses wasn't
trying to like blend in to be a tourist
i thought comments was like oh look i
was trying to blend in to be a tourist
i'm like no we knew he was there what do
you think people thought he like snuck
in oh
no he's filming no but people were like
oh he's trying to blunt yo i don't
understand this comment the only person
laughing at ethan on the bus was trish
was laughing at me the microphone you
couldn't pick it up oh yeah so it didn't
sound like i was the only one i was like
i was crushing that bus why is everyone
scooping a mic in the back with like the
people everyone was like oh ethan's
bombing but trish is being so supportive
i was like that's not how i remember it
no no they were laughing you just
couldn't pick it up because that's what
i'm wearing all right thank you
i was like what i was like should i bomb
it's not a santa it's not a comedy show
i know but like if you're not funny and
you're bombing everyone's just sitting
there all straight faced and you're the
only one laughing
also i was supposed to show up as
spider-man hollywood they dressed up as
spiderman and i [ __ ] forgot it you're
the one who told me then i had to change
my whole office i had a sad boy like
overall outfit i was wearing all right
we're going costume i had it right by
the door i had this great spiderman
outfit with the muscles and [ __ ]
and i just i was like okay do i have
everything and i was like i got
everything and i [ __ ] forgot it i
mean that's like the biggest thing you
could remember you're going to film what
are you going to wear like that's the
biggest thing to remember that's crazy
you look good as marilyn though thank
you i tried i was like okay we're going
to be hollywood boulevard people like
that's my thing it didn't even look like
weird you just looked like you were you
were killing it that day oh thank you
yeah um thank you
it was a good time
oh there's one other thing
you want to talk about something about
[ __ ] yeah what do you want to talk about
but there's so many i don't even know
like i was i was i was racking up a list
you know what it is i think i've been
doing better at like managing my
insanity because i don't do videos for
everything i want to snap back on
because i'm like all to talk about on
the podcast because in the past i would
do like 20 videos on one day i'm like
well i'm not really organized like you
but i have a ton tell me all right go
ahead i'll i'll go down the list and you
can tell me so um sophia franklin who's
from caller daddy or whatever
she like anyways okay just i'll go down
listen what did she do give me
yeah so sophia franklin who's not on
card yet she's the one that like left or
whatever because she wasn't getting
enough money she has her own podcast
this was like a big thing and she
basically like
that's not that interesting now it was
like last week's news whatever
so like there was this tick tocker she
like sent her a message and the tick
tocker left her on red so then she went
off and called her like a disgusting
[ __ ] and all this crazy [ __ ] and reader
dm yeah and the girl was like super
sweet like she's like this like i don't
check my dm yeah and then the girl was
just like and i guess she got like a ton
of hate or whatever but anyways that was
like one thing happened okay all right
um loser and green green tried to cancel
me oh he didn't did you see that i saw
he said one about how you were you're
faking being dumb and then halfway
through he's like but first of all can i
say hey first off flattery because
there's a hankering the one that did the
cancer movie the girl with the cancer
i don't know i think he wrote that right
dan did he did he's a smart man he did
yeah he wrote this big movie i think
he also did vidcon which is also trash
so he did like a really great movie
about the girl with cancer but then he
did a trash of vidcon i don't know i
guess take your poison but like he's
good on one hand but i was like damn why
are you trying to cancel me because i
wait i thought he made a nice video
about you no definitely like um what's
the name hank green cancels trisha
paytas oh and then he deleted it because
he got so much hate he deleted it he did
and he got so much hate
wait wait wait wait i watched it and i
thought it was flattering to you
she's not it's all an act because he was
like oh she knows what carbon monoxide
monoxide can i tell you hand to god
square on my mother's life who i love
more than anything i do not know the
difference between monoxide and dioxide
i've heard people say carbon dioxide
carbon monoxide i don't know what the
hell each one is but i don't know where
in my life i couldn't tell you what
global warming is something about
florida you said it was melting off the
earth but i've never gone about
canceling you i got to speak up for he
did everyone was giving him [ __ ] like
why are you trying to cancel trisha he
wasn't oh my god i saw everyone say it
hold on we gotta find the tick
i thought it was why did he delete it
probably because he was like what is
wrong with these psychotic tricia first
of all thank you to my psychos out there
i love you that's what i'm like no when
i watch that i thought it was flattering
because first of all he knows who you
are epic epic epic and then second of
all he's like
being like oh she's so she's smart look
she knows stuff like she's just goofing
around that's not how i took from it but
also like i don't know those things
don't tell me what i know i don't know
oh and by the way i agree i whenever i
see people be like oh she's pretending
to be dumb i'm like
but not that i don't think you're dumb
she pretending not to know things
like with gravity and stuff
no can i tell i shouldn't say who i
heard it from that is moses knows he
knows i heard that from another podcast
where someone said gravity was what it
was that someone invented like you know
a podcast i'm talking about i'm not
going to say it i can't say it because
we're it's
not josh she'll be named no it's someone
i can't talk about but you know if you
know the person that's blocked and
banned from our show
being talked about you know
anyways
that i did hear this from someone else
and i never even thought about it i
never thought i just i was like oh that
makes sense because this person made a
valid argument of why like we don't need
gravity and i was like oh [ __ ]
and i swear i heard it and i and i
thought oh i i thought the person was
going to call me out for copying her
because it was real i was like but i but
i was trying to think of the person
because at the time i really didn't know
the person now i remember oh [ __ ] that
person but i was it was a person's
podcast and i was like oh that makes
sense and then i said it and i was like
no i i agree dude i'm with you i think
everything
i think you are 100 authentic i'm 100
smart i'm
dear evan hansen ben platt no thank you
to me
listen we're just talking about
knowledge i think you're your brain you
are obviously very intelligent and funny
you have intelligence doesn't mean i
know but do you know what gravity is no
do i know what global warming is no no
do i care no hell no
it's just like one of those things where
it's like damn i i mean it's fine but
also i was just like but let's watch
this because i personally think he was
doing you an honor but if you read all
the comments everyone's like [ __ ] him
you know what i mean well i'm not
surprised why because because i don't
know actually yeah why does got to say
call out he's not calling you out so
nervous i was like exposed by angry
because i don't think he does drama he
doesn't want to be involved drama but
like his video okay watch carbon in the
air carbon monoxide or dioxide both you
know that the earth this is an
illustrative moment so trisha paytas but
do you see how he's honoring you he goes
this moment and the podcast is
illustrious
what's a
luster what that is no it's creative
illustrative yes yeah illustrative what
does that mean though
that's not a nice thing
it's not a bad picture i'm drawing a
picture oh my god dude no wonder he took
it down
who's this illustrious look at him with
the book behind it
he has a big platform and he's talking
about it so why has everyone got a [ __ ]
on him to make him erase it like hello
he's being a sweetheart i don't know
being a sweetheart because he's exposing
me but he's not okay okay let's play it
oh man so trisha paytas is saying that
she
hasn't heard of car of global warming
and then ethan says you don't know about
carbon in the air and then she says
carbon monoxide or carbon dioxide
if your if your response to carbon in
the air is which carbon oxide
you know
stuff
you know stuff
okay and one of the things you know is
global warming not calling she's
pretending to not know
that's the game
she's
playing i guess we all know that she's
playing a character i think i'm the only
one that doesn't know that because i see
people saying that all the time i'm like
what character there's no [ __ ]
character
i i don't know but i'll thank you but i
think why people think that's because
you're inconsistent like you'll make a
video from three years ago being like
this is everything i know about the
holocaust in detail right then when you
come on the podcast and i go and i you
go what's the holocaust right how do you
explain that well that holocaust video
in particular there's a lot of cuts i
would stop and look at my phone all the
time yeah hey guys like you know what i
mean i used to do that all the time with
political stuff like before i went on
like i remember i went on larry king how
many people died in the holocaust
literally no idea
take a guess thousands
really
thousands hundreds of thousands a
million a million
how many jews died in the holocaust you
need to know this but to get you jews
are people okay let's start with jews oh
my god how many jews died in the
holocaust two million i'm starting
conversion classes tonight you better
[ __ ] know that
that's what they ask you when you step
inside there's that much he's kind of
like whatever six million six million
pretty much all of them that is how many
people mcdonald's serves when you go to
mcdonald's that's serving six million
people or is it billion
[Laughter]
just kidding for every jew that dies in
the holocaust we will serve one
hamburger that is our pledge to the
world oh [ __ ]
oh man we should go to the hog people
who died in the holocaust was like uh
eight or ten million or something or
twelve i don't know had a million oh
they were just [ __ ] where did they
all come from i didn't know there was
countries with that well they were
killing communism gays and dis political
dissidents so it wasn't just how did
they tell the gays because jews were
wearing star david gays were wearing
pink triangle right really a triangle
they had different symbols for you don't
know even i don't remember the gay uh
symbol but damn oh triangles yeah that
makes sense tinky winky had the triangle
on his head and everyone said he was gay
oh that was illuminati this triangle
sorry nothing but like no they were they
were yeah in nazi concentration camp
yeah trying homosexual
upside down they were killing gypsies
too right then they were they're tipsy
slavs communists
yeah pretty much anybody why don't we
play gypsies because borah hated gypsies
too in the movie why do people play
gypsies like why seriously aren't they
just trying to make a living
i think it's actually politically
incorrect to call them gypsies
oh really well they're romanian right
they're like romanian ones hungarian too
roma it's different than romanian oh oh
cause they're like you can't still call
them gypsies no i oh that's new again
i'm not a neck i'm just trying to learn
i'm just trying to learn peace and love
i wish we could go to the hot cosplay
probably would be that exciting can't
make jokes or anything i would love to
go just to go you want to make a comedy
video want to make like a comedy vlog at
the holocaust i said it wouldn't be
exciting because you couldn't but i
still would love to go just like look at
it
go who's stopping no together all of us
bro how is that going to be fun take
theodore it's educational i'm not i'm
not going on a special family day to the
holocaust with you
you have to watch schindler's list first
well i can't it's black and white
maybe if it was color like and gloria's
bastards there's some color is there oh
i didn't get that far it was all black
and white that we watched so anyway here
let's let's finish okay well to not know
that's the game she's playing
i guess we all know that she's playing a
character
and everybody's playing a character but
like kevin carpenter i'm so confused the
point of it though i guess just like
give me a shout out she's smart it was
nice he's saying she's smart and she's
playing this character but she's
pretending to not know stuff but she
knows stuff i know that you started
vidcon and the cancer movie i knew that
i'm [ __ ] green i could have been i
don't know him it's hank green's brother
made the cancer movie whoa
what's his name
uh john green
i looked it up because i had no idea
what you were talking about
oh so what did hank green do no offense
but what did he do isn't he an author
he's like a famous author no john
green's the author he wrote the
documentary they made the movies gotta
get the [ __ ] straight oh poor hank green
isn't that awful like your brother wait
what's the one we just watched hank
that's hank i like hank i like john
i like john too okay but i i follow hank
i like his tick tock what did hank do
though hank's known for something right
he's
oh i don't think he's an author no one
of them is an author
john is the author
he's like he's gotta get there it's too
many hanks and they look the same they
do look the same there's not there's
just one hank there's there's not too
many hanks
okay but what is hank green what about
tom hanks dan
no that's not even in this realm
he's dancing there's only one hank
when the topic of the green brothers
there's only one hank okay they're right
but what did hank green do what it is
he's a youtuber he's he's
an educational he does education he
reminds me of rhett and link like those
people all are the same but do you see
what i'm saying like the fact that
people are giving him [ __ ] for that is
just so messed up well blame death
noodles i love duff noodles but he's a
call out trisha paytas exposed and i was
like i started like panicking right away
it was not a call out it was so not a
call out you know i one time stood
upright and link
i blanked on them like you're supposed
to go on the show and you bailed no no
it was like when i was like 18 like when
youtube first started maybe 19 because
they were an og and i got an l.a casting
and i didn't know who they were they're
like right link is paying 50 for like to
be in a car washing i swear and i was
supposed to go to the car wash and they
kept they wouldn't call me but like
their assistant or someone kept calling
me all day like where are you
i was just like on drugs i was just like
chilling big mistake hiring you
and i never i i know back in the day i
think i was blacklisted from alley
casting but i was supposed to be in a
written link video a long time ago but
are they still crushing it i feel like
they're still like low-key here in the
world yeah oh yeah bretton lake those
guys are the best how old are they
though they're probably older than me
huh old as [ __ ] stop don't be ageist but
they're super like healthy
like looking or physically no like they
are like they like really take care of
themselves they're like slender and like
healthy looking that doesn't mean
they're healthy just because they're
skinny
no i can tell they're healthy you can't
tell that by looking at somebody look at
me you could tell i'm unhealthy they're
43 and 42.
oh they're like the fine bros before the
fine bros got cancelled these guys will
never get cancelled really hopefully
what did they do though what if they do
something like that
like bill gates look at him getting
cancelled now no no no no i'm
keep them pure no okay what else you got
on your list okay okay okay um
my list actually like i make it during
the weeks i'm so angry and then like
candace i'm like i have like
my
it says pringles can because my hand
won't fit a pringles can not that
exciting
i don't know why they do make them so
small not a big topic but well hold on
pringle cans are kind of fat shaming yes
i try to get my hand in there like no
joke i always heard it as a joke but i
literally
i was so triggered i was like wow they
really are like don't eat this
and then i saw someone do a life hack
where they put a piece of paper in and
they like they pour it out so you can
get the paper on like this on the back
people pringle hacks why are they so
little that is kind of that is well they
make it to fit the chip but i see what
you mean i've had another idea for a
vlog and equally i'm kind of embarrassed
that my hand does fit in it because you
have baby hands yeah uh mine are mammoth
hands look how big my hands are you're
fat [ __ ] monsters no they are i blame
the liposuction because honestly i feel
all the fat is going to my hands my
hands have looked chubbier and chubbier
i'm not that is an interesting theory
there's no veins no bones it's just fat
you guys can't fit in the pringle can be
honest
yeah yeah okay good he's got little
hands up too dan be honest dan i think
so yeah okay so i don't need pringles
regularly let's do a pringle hand check
that's the thing can you just pour them
out of the tube
who does that
who would pour it out of the tube only
cat people do that then i had i had a
rylan oh matthew perry and ben affleck i
want there's so many there's rylan
matthew perry ben affleck bryce hall
eugenia cooney chad michael murray okay
one at a time here jesus christ i know i
have so many i'm going to explode i want
to say my name do you want to egg me for
a video sure i would love to get egg i
was like why do you want me to egg you i
watched them i was watching never been
kissed which used to be one of my
favorite movies with drew barrymore and
she gets egged before going to prom i'm
like that's iconic i want to recreate it
for like a music video or something no
just for rhyme is this like a only fans
thing i just want to get egged i'll like
you sure so should we talk about which
one is i think like ryland ben affleck
or um what's what did rylan do did you
see his
so not see it's so funny because i have
i talked to most about this stuff i get
so riled up and i'm talking about i'm
like it's not that i'm like nobody cares
i just see like you know i watch the
drama channel talk about it um he
basically was uh like telling his
viewers to stop complaining that like oh
he was pissed at his viewers because his
viewers were like oh thank you finally
an hour long video but the way he said
it was like uh everyone's saying thank
you finding an hour-long podcast like he
was like mocking them and everyone's
like they're like why don't you just be
grateful people are watching which is
kind of true
she's like uh isn't it nice that people
want more content yeah but he's like no
it's it's the way they said it she goes
no you're putting aggression in the tone
i don't know what it is and i'm biased
i'm biased 100 rylan is a snake snake
steak when he said that [ __ ] that he
didn't know about me and jeffree star i
was like you are such a [ __ ] liar
against her so i'm a bias but i was so
pissed you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna
just say i'm a little petty i like to
you know i as i do with some podcasts i
like to hate watch or whatever because
i'm like oh my god but watching that
made my blood boil because the way he
was like mocking that mocking town where
he's like dan yeah oh god that's noodles
has got it for sure
our ian back he do it like that though
oh i just can't stand him his little
smugness like everything about and he's
just a liar he's the snake in the grass
the one that i've always said that solar
soldier's devil rylan adams for sure but
wait is shane the devil
i i would say no they both sold their
soul to the devil is shane coming back
what's the deal with that you have
insider info
no i don't i because i feel like i can't
look at them i can't look at them like
it makes me literally hold on i remember
once on this podcast when you're still
friends with shane you were like he's
about to make a comeback and then you
stopped yourself i think he was yeah i
think he i mean he might i don't know i
just i can't yeah i mean i don't know he
was close to a month you know a while
ago i don't know so here's rylan uh that
apparently ruined your weekend ruined my
week
it just made me
so angry i'm like this guy you know
not as popular as you were you're only
known for being engaged to shane and
you're gonna complain that people leave
comments saying thank you for a longer
video like they're thanking you and you
took it as a mocking tone all right i
would live it oh my god
i don't know it's
i have so much like i see red i don't
know how you can get through the day
when [ __ ] like this makes you so angry
let's watch them you know what i do i
watch girls next to horny it
decompresses me it does big cd and girls
next door here we go wow i was pretty
upset over this past week about the
podcast oh you were yeah what happened
all of the comments were like finally a
podcast not cut down to nothing
no why would you be upset about that
people love us they want more i tell you
this every week it's the aggression in
which they approach oh my god
bro there's no tone hey dude you should
see what we say about you if that makes
you angry don't watch this oh my god
oh it made me so angry and the way he
did that tone like um finally a pocket
so it's like that's not what they're
saying like thank you for being here
they always ask us to make us longer oh
i wish frenemies are throughout they're
giving you i mean no they're giving you
feedback bro they want they want you to
not edit it that was what made him angry
all week was people being like oh we
want a longer podcast from you like oh
so just self-absorbed i just i hate
devil i look at it and i see devil and
i'm not i don't say that lightly i don't
say that lightly you think he's a devil
he made a deal with the devil it's in
him oh my god when i watch that clip of
him being like trisha never told us oh
my i've never seen someone just lie just
cold face lie when they know the trauma
that i've been through with that person
and i was like i'm still so heated by it
so when i see these i don't try and
watch it because it does make me heated
but i saw this on the deaf noodle so i
watched the whole thing for context and
he was just so smug and arrogant i'm
like be lucky you barely break a hundred
thousand views and so do my main channel
videos and i'm lucky that if they break
a hundred thousand views be lucky you
break a hundred thousand views like it's
insane to me that he thinks that like
he's putting tone to comments that are
being nice holy [ __ ] he had a disabled
just like you know oh all right let me
what let me watch let me watch lizzie
should get her own podcast i like her i
stand her 100
the fact that she even had to explain it
like what are you talking about they
like us like
so self-absorbed he's so self-absorbed
and narcissistic don't watch this rylan
i get so angry you're sensitive don't
watch this approach it's appreciated
you're creating the aggression in your
articulation they're creating the
aggression in the way that they're
saying they appreciate a longer podcast
they could just say oh my gosh i'm so
excited for the hour-long podcast
oh what the [ __ ] are these conditions
you're requiring they should say it like
this if someone says hey we want
five-hour friend enemies i'm gonna like
let's try and make it happen we talked
about going along you know what i mean
people do say that and it's a compliment
they like our show they want more good
enough they wanted to go longer it's
like my whole week is ruined because
people want longer they want to watch
more of our show oh i'm sorry
that made me angry that triggered me in
such a way i was like how unappreciative
are you that like people don't care
about you anymore like they just don't
they never did anyways you were always
like a sidekick but now they really
don't care about you and you still can't
be appreciative like that's how you're
gonna get canceled you're gonna get
canceled by doing that by yourself
you're gonna cancel yourself because
you're so unappreciative it's so well
i mean yeah is it it's a good general
rule to not [ __ ] [ __ ] on your own
audience
especially when they're actually being
nice dude like the ones that actually
like you
and and they filter the comments
everyone's nice so i don't know what
he's reading they're always nice
comments i went through and i went
through recently and they were all super
nice yeah they're all they're all like
we love you even he's like oh you know
who you know who i hate the most people
that like this show
they're the [ __ ] worst anyways it
made me like so so angry okay wait let
me watch this i have some idea you've
been ranting about it for like 10
minutes
that isn't cut all the way down to
nothing this is essentially a vlog show
and yeah they're watching and
subscribing and living and loving and
grateful for more time this girl's like
please don't [ __ ] yourself
she's like this is my only gig please
don't [ __ ] and in all fairness those
commenters it is a vlog podcast they go
through the drive-through like they're
like you know they're doing mukbangs
they did the you know the james corden
gig like they do do vlogs for their
podcast it's a it is a vlog podcast i
don't know why he's like complaining
about that you shoot your own thing but
i'm like so i think you should wait
should see the silver lining in this so
that we can talk and talk and talk and
that these people love it
i am very appreciative that they like
the longer episodes i can't believe
that's what you were upset about well it
just like some of the aggression and
there were some that were just if their
podcast gets cancelled should we hire
her for something a thousand percent
that'd be awesome i'll do that vlog yeah
getting my coffee we need a female we
need a female touchscreen
it's like i think it's like how people
think that you and i are constantly on
the brink of like fencing to the death
i think that you're hearing the
aggression where people are hearing that
you and i are okay ryan you're canceled
it's just also like you can't spend the
whole podcast talking about the podcast
comments like oh my god i don't know
whatever i was over that's how they got
the no he was literally like you know
who i hate who ruined my whole [ __ ]
week people that liked this show
yeah can i tell you another person that
like ruined my week yeah if you have one
more do you guys like that i have
nothing to tell you it's trisha howard
sorry
give me your hand no i'm kidding i don't
touch you
no we accidentally touched hands which
is very intimate kind of like to hand
touch
and i didn't like it
on purpose i know i'm just saying i'm
just breaking down the moment the other
one the other one right
oh my god the other one that maybe
somebody matthew perry okay so friends
reunion no no what is that even
happening i don't even know i never
thought i didn't watch it though
but oh no
no he okay so there's this like there's
this pattern now of these like so it was
ben affleck for us getting exposed you
see that one right his riot someone yeah
yeah we talked about that oh matthew
perry got caught so matthew
i've heard matthew perry's a total d-bag
oh he's he's been on raya for a minute i
know tons of people have talked about
their experience with him on on on raya
is the app which i think ryan never
accept accepted me because i've always
talked [ __ ] about like the people that
are on ryan you got rejected for mariah
yeah all the time
oh yeah now celebrity i didn't well
right because i'm engaged but you think
it's because you're not famous enough
i think i talked homie i don't know
maybe i was thinking because i talk [ __ ]
about people like famous people and
stuff like that like back in the day i
was always like exposing people but
these girls are doing it so this girl
recorded her facetime call with matthew
perry and the audacity of these guys on
tic tac i went off this the one guy on
tick tock was like oh these cloud
tasters like here i have it i can
probably pull it up
death noodles got it you got everything
that's awesome good i didn't see jeff
noodles cover it i covered it like when
i saw the ben affleck one i felt bad i
was like oh it's funny by the way he's
like why did you unmatch me it's me
oh right and people were thinking like
oh that's like a clown clown chaser well
you know i'm the guy
well you know they should just assume
like celebrities should just assume here
i'll get it for you
i'm so funny the ben affleck one it's me
why did you unmatch me it's me yeah that
was like weird here pull that one up too
i want to watch for people haven't seen
it
i don't know okay so here's the ben
affleck one just so you guys know who
because i think it's hilarious although
i feel bad for him
just because there was no reason for
this girl
to post this publicly kind of if she
unmatched him she'd match him for a
reason why is he like it's me
hold on hold on hold on in her tick tock
she said she unmatched him because she
thought it was a fake account
but he didn't know that she said that in
the tick tock after he sent her this she
didn't tell her maybe they did have a
conversation like you're fake and then
you don't know that you're assuming the
way i would assume that she doesn't
match him because she wasn't didn't want
to match him no she said i thought it
was fake
okay anyway here's ben
why did you unmatch me
it's me
he sent her a dm on instagram i don't
think that's unworthy why did you
unmatch me that's so weird
look dudes can do much weirder [ __ ]
let's be honest he was just like it's me
they're celebrities going after young
girls they should know they're gonna
post these to social media i know that
all the time i would date celebrities
and be like oh i'm gonna expose you now
like that's just what you do at that age
like you just think like oh this is
funny
it's me i love that that's the best
pickup line ever yeah yeah
why did you unmatch me it's me like also
he doesn't say his name it's like [ __ ]
you know who i am why did you unmatch me
it's me
so she said caption it said thinking of
the time i matched with ben affleck on
rhea and thought it was fake so i
unmatched him and he sent me a video on
instagram but clearly she wasn't
interested because
she posted this right that's what i'm
saying i mean i think they're just like
i don't know why she said she unmatched
them because she thought it was fake it
makes me think they had a conversation
where she's like you're a fake bye but
she didn't ask for some videos it's only
like oh send me a video oh i mean we
don't know that why did you want to
match what you get this dm from ben
affleck what do you do
it creeps me out now like even back then
i don't know i think as a young girl
wow but
it's me it's scary ah
just go away that's scary it's scary
it's funny it's kind of raya it's so
weird to me like i know that's why she
was like what the [ __ ] okay well now
that matthew perry won okay so now let's
watch my favorite i've been seeing so
many people go against this poor girl
for recording it honestly like i get i
get like okay why are you recording but
also these people are 50 going for a 19
year old like what do you expect like
yeah that girl is really young i agree
ben affleck's like what 50 now he's 50
matthew perry's over 50. and that girl
looks like
20s early 20s yeah and this girl with
that matthew perry is facetiming 19. oh
matthew you dog like you sick they
shouldn't let people over 40 go with
teenagers even if they're legal like 19
that's literally a teenager like what i
mean
they're adults and i talked to the girls
i talked to the girl matthew perry
because i was like she was getting
ripped on the internet i said hey she's
already following me so i was like okay
let me watch it because i don't know
what happened matthew perry is being
wrongfully me chewed by desperate tick
tockers and the story comes oh this
guy's got the slant
i know right away write out the game
poor matthew perry is being killed also
looks 50 and she wasn't saying she was
me too don't use that and then also what
do you say desperate take talkers like
already just the misogyny okay let me
see what happened let me see what
happened before i give my value judgment
here i went crazy on this guy i was
joining the popular
which has 8.5 million users there we
match with 19 year old tick tock model
kate harrelson and i understand a 19
year old matching with a 50 year old is
very strange but ray does allow age
filters for all users they match and
matthew perry asked if she'd like to
facetime and she did say yes and from
that she recorded the entire
conversation which was meant to be
private and released it on her tik tok
getting millions of views harrelson got
some fame for it initially but decided
to delete the video and also disable any
comments on our tick tock or instagram
post matthew perry on the other hand
said he's at risk of losing several
movie gigs that are coming up for him
and this is not the first time it
happened where model nadine j did the
same thing to ben affleck wait it's the
same oh okay yeah okay
i'm sorry dude but it's hilarious it's
yeah okay but what did he say
and that video is the only thing to ever
go viral on our tick tock with eight
point six million people shut up
whatever legend's wife chrissy teigen
called both men okay dude you're not
you're not telling me what the
conversation was i swear there was a lot
i thought that was hold on sorry this
guy's like this [ __ ] desperate tick
tucker wait let me trade my main man
matthew perry my favorite character from
friends hold on i have the video hold on
i have the video maybe while you find it
i'll tell this anecdote okay louis ck
even trashed on matthew perry and one of
us stands up he goes he was at uh or
maybe there's a podcast i listened to
but he's like we were at this like uh
movie preview or something and all the
drinks were free
and then louis c.k left like a 20 tip
for the waitress and matthew perry's
like
what are you doing you know you don't
have to tip right he said he told the
story yeah he told the story publicly
he's like what do you mean he's like
they just because the drinks are free
doesn't mean that they they should work
for free a homework and he's like you
don't have to tip dude it's all free
yeah louise is so weird
like oh my god that's a lot to somebody
the fact that he slammed him publicly
made me be like wow he must really hate
yeah i just like it i've always heard
like creepy stories about him so what
did he say
here it is i brought it in the group
chat oh here's send it in discord dan
how do i get in the discord do i kind of
be on the discord
i downloaded it for one day and then
deleted it i was like okay i know and i
was trying to see what you were seeing
because i know you were like
i saw you like would say stuff and i
went to read it but then they were like
being mean and i was like i got it off
right now yeah i read it yeah i thought
they were nice you told me reddit liked
me and then i went on there and they're
like [ __ ] trisha
it always happens every few years i
always get a [ __ ] trisha
just a bunch
yeah really because they hate me too
don't worry
nobody hates me quite like hp podcast
fans
okay here we go i'm just pulling your
eyelids no it's true okay
okay here we go okay all right here is
the infamous
my boy
my boy matthew perry the one and only
true big dog
nobody how many [ __ ]
intro slates do we need
okay here it is all right
um i guess
do you always play with your hair
[Music]
um
that's it no there was more there was
more it was basically i can't find the
video it was basically like a video of
him being like am i as old am i older
than your dad like it's just like those
kind of questions like
i don't know where the full video is i
think it really was taken down
[Music]
no it wasn't that it's like tell me am i
older than your dad like when people say
that i used to i hooked up with an actor
when i was 21 and he'd always be like
remind me of your age how old are you
like it was so weird he was like 53.
yeah and he's like he goes hold your dad
it was the same thing so i reached out
to that girl because i was like girl i
know you're getting [ __ ] on the internet
about daughters because i feel like they
go like i don't think he has kids i
don't think matthew perry has kids but
it's but a lot of the guy i was with did
he was like i feel like it's always like
oh you're the [ __ ] like he gets off on
the knowing it's the same age no that's
what it is so i was telling her i was
like um and ever but everyone was
dogging on the girl being like oh well
she's at the age that's like she wanted
that age it's like
ryerson even a lot i was so i was so
pissed about it and you know what no nor
like i don't say normal but no
a teenager never with a 50 year old i
was a teenager a 50 year old i was like
16 with a 50 year old i was 18 with a 50
year old i was like with the 50 year old
yeah oh my god my whole life i was
people with people over 50. like
literally 40 started getting a little oh
that's just like straight that's like
but to that point is like i thought i
wanted that too a lot of people like
some people just prefer older men when i
was 19 i thought i wanted to date this
50 year old and it's like it's so they
[ __ ] you up so much in your head it's
not just me it's any guy any 50 year old
who wants to be a 19 year old you're
[ __ ] in the head you are [ __ ] in
that i don't care if they say if they
say you're a mature for your age red
flag that's a huge red flag
they're just trying to do something
weird they're they're sick they're sick
in the head and that's why i have so
much issue with like
i'm not well i won't say it but there's
other people that are over 40 trying to
get with like teenagers 18 year olds 19
year old 20 year old 21 year old it's
sick and i see i saw this 21 year old i
was hooking up with a 48 year old
youtuber and she was like he said he was
going to marry me and all this [ __ ] and
it's like who why are you telling this
to [ __ ] 20 year old girls like you're
[ __ ] with their heads like it's so
not cool now of course that person would
go like i would expose them too when i
was 21 i was exposing every celebrity i
did it with because they would [ __ ] me
up because i mean the truth is
matthew it's on matthew perry to defend
himself not this girl like bro like you
said if you're if you're skyping in
doing a face chat a face time with like
an 18 year old like
bro you you already lost exactly it's
like you're the celebrity you're the
older one you don't you know what tick
tock is you know what social media is
grandpa like
this the truth is up until like 10 years
ago it was just commonplace that these
old rich celebrity dudes were just
[ __ ] and dating young girls and
they're like this is all good this is
why i made it but only like in the past
10 years these guys need to like reign
it in because people are being like
that's not cool it's so gross i called
them out even when i was that age i
remember when i aged out at like 21 i
was calling people out that were [ __ ]
me when i was like 19 and they were
[ __ ] 50 year old actors and i was
like you're disgusting you want to name
one no i've already named some of them
they're not anyone like whatever but
anthony michael hall roger bart
christman glover oh my god wait let me
google these anthony anthony what
yeah we've talked about this before we
talked about this from breakfast club 16
candles roger bart was an actor he
strung me along for three years he was
like he was the one that'd be like how
old are you i was like girl anthony
mccall
gross
oh glover oh yeah i know about anthony
chris glover crispin
chris mclover crispin glover
crispin glover how the [ __ ] crispin
you would know look i mean what like
what kind of name future
i didn't know about chris oh he always
[ __ ] young girls like he's so he and
the ones that are sick like one's a like
almost you know he's he's just like
really well i don't know he's another
grosso so this guy was just in back to
future that's all charlie's angels the
movie with the rats
holy [ __ ]
yeah he was he and he's like i only like
girls like over 20 like under 21 like he
would like i aged out for him at 21. you
know what i mean like
that just goes to show how a tiny bit of
fame like these guys there was a guy
roger bar who [ __ ] with me for like
four years and said the same [ __ ] like
we're gonna get married
yeah bart
bart he has me blocky hates me i'm
trying to restrain like not a lawsuit
after oh who's this [ __ ]
he was in like revenge like i don't know
he's been in a lot of [ __ ] and he he was
one that i literally lost my [ __ ] he was
the first person i made like an exposed
video he didn't movie with shane at the
time and
one of these other people named he did a
movie with shane i mean that's rock
bottom shane and totally that's like
your career is dead i mean honestly
and he
he was so manipulative with me one
minute and then he would just like cut
me off he's like i'm never talking to
you again so i made the exposed video on
him i'm like and he had like a whole
like wife and children and all this [ __ ]
like that but he was telling me like oh
he would fly me to sets in toronto new
york he's like we're going to get
married let me move in with you i got a
house so we can move in with and it's
like what do you expect when you tell 22
years you're going to marry it like now
i look stupid of course i'm looking back
i'm like oh of course i was so dumb and
stupid
why shouldn't you believe the person
you're with that they're lying to i mean
that's insane i'll just say it there's
another there's a girl that made a whole
video but she was hooking up with jason
nash for the past like three years she's
like 22 and she was he said he was going
to marry me it was the same situation i
was like these [ __ ] like stop it
these girls are going to believe you and
you think
do you think these guys are
intentionally lying just to manipulate
these girls
because that to me seems so evil and
[ __ ] up we can't take pictures
together don't tell friends about me
like the roger would say the same thing
and this is what jason was telling this
girl and she has like a whole video
about it and stuff like that it's like
it's like
do these guys get together and like
strategize because what's with them
they're all telling girls like i'm going
to marry you
seems like um that just seems like so
evil it's so it's so awful because they
would say stuff like or you know oh
just a ton of [ __ ] like pisses me off to
no end because then the girls get [ __ ]
like even that girl that made the video
about jason they're like oh my god she
sounds so stupid like so dumb it's like
blame the man he's [ __ ] 48 telling
this like 21 year old that they're gonna
get married when she's 26. it was so
specific to me like when you're 26 we're
gonna get married and i'm like this girl
is gonna waste your whole life like i
did with these guys i wasted years with
roger bart for like four years she
couldn't anyone contestant will shake
cancer anymore because i don't like him
but anyone could have tested that like i
was like i'm gonna marry this guy i
didn't date anybody else i was so loyal
to this person and i wasted like 20 to
like 24 just obsessed with this guy same
thing with anthony mccall from like a
young age to 20. it's just like you
think that what was the guy's name that
you that you said shane knew roger bart
do you think roger bert looks back on
the time he collab with shane as the
moment his career took a nosedive
he might because he won a tony award
before that so maybe oh yeah from tony
to shane
no good oh man he's gonna kill me i'm
gonna get a lawsuit after this i'm sure
[ __ ] i mean it's truth it's all truth so
whatever he's blocked me so many times
but whatever i don't care how many times
can you block you
like everywhere just everywhere um
eugene and cooney have you seen her
latest video people are i don't know i'm
on the fence about this okay let me pull
it up it's hard to i have a hard time
watching hers because
i just feel bad for her that's the whole
point is people are like why is youtube
like allowing this why are people
supporting this she's clearly some
people are saying she's clearly
supporting
she's trying to enable the lifestyle she
has of being like actually very skinny
like to the point which is the one
adjusting the hate summer outfits no
it's the summer outfits when everyone's
mad at
so today her and youtube they're like
why is she promoting this to her fans is
she promoting it is she's promoting her
body or is she just showing up well go
to the end because i feel like
as like does um want to look like this
or is it just like you the perception of
yourself is like
do they think this because i think so i
think some people want to look like this
i think when i was young i thought that
was the beauty i still this is how
warped i am like i'm like oh you can
never be too skinny so i have to really
read into this because i'm like oh why
are people like shaming her like that's
what people want to look like like in my
head i don't think it looks terrible
but i've been reading comments and i
guess people are like it's the point
because she's she used to be purple her
legs
she's about to die okay so she denied
for a long time eating disorder then she
said she did have a disorder and got
like treatment now she's back and she's
clearly still
kind of fast like okay no she's about to
die she has no so people are like why
i guess there's a couple stance like
shane did a documentary on her and
youtube promoted it and they're like why
is youtube promoting this and then now
she's making videos like why are you
promoting this to your young fans you're
clearly sick like i never saw the shane
documentary but like what was the
conclusion it seems like he was probably
trying to help right
i actually have never seen so i don't
know
but i was saying i saw someone make that
point that youtube was promoting his
series and so therefore promoting her
and then people are like why is she
promoting this to young her to her fans
which on one hand i don't is she
promoting her diet her or she just
showing bikini i think it could be the
same argue of a meat eating right like
me eating is like oh you're promoting
obesity like maybe it's the same
argument i don't know i'm kind of on the
fence with it it's not trending
oh it is probably can't see this number
26 on trending oh wow it was definitely
a big thing i saw it all so you said go
to the end here let's watch a bit so
wait the trending page is curated oh
yeah that's trending
well there so they straight up they've
given the green they someone has
manually reviewed this so they're like
how is youtube promoting this to like
okay well let's see let's see
can you turn it up um but i thought it
still works as a summer dress or just
really whatever you want to wear this or
something like this i guess after
showing you guys that first i got music
i mean you can literally see her no she
she's she's like about to die i feel
like i guess that's why people are like
why is no one giving her like getting
her off the internet and like helping
her but people have been saying that
about her for years well i guess she did
go get help
and she kind of took a break and now i
do i am surprised youtube's trending
this though like why are they going out
of their way it could just be because
people are talking about it you know
but then on one hand is like is she just
living her life like she has a disease
and she's just trying to like live her
life i guess i don't know or i don't
know well would you say that about
someone who's no no no you can't i don't
think you can say that she
she's killing her i mean what would you
say about like a vicious i don't know i
don't i
i don't either
she's just living her life
would you say that about someone who's
like strung out on heroin about to die
of like an overdose any day
it's kind of like i don't know i don't
know but it's kind of like me eating
fast food like am i slowly killing
myself probably you know what i mean
like
or any fat person those people who are
600 pounds you know what i mean and
they're just eating well there's a
difference between you and a 600 pound
person okay so like a 600 pound person
eating would you say he's just living
his life um not real i mean no i'm not
saying i'm thinking it's kind of the
equivalent like yes they're killing
themselves yeah i'm trying i'm i'm
exploring the moral dilemma here in my
head i don't know either because some
people online just have to make really
big can she really not help it maybe she
just can't help
well she definitely has a disease i'm
sure she would prefer to be healthy and
normal if she could [ __ ] flip a
switch in her brain
but people have been talking about her
for years like she needs help this is a
new thing though like this is that now
because she's showing her body again
like clearly showing i don't know i'm so
confused with it i'm so torn on it too
people are saying she's doing it on
purpose
because she knows people are so angry
and she continues to i don't know
you know what i'll just say like people
are saying she's
catering to fetishism
people who like that because someone
said the thumbnail apparently is really
racy compared to what she wears
right she shows her swimsuit and her
legs and i don't know but she doesn't
show her whole body in the video
why did they trend this it only has 120
000 views youtube is really [ __ ]
weird i swear to god i
yeah
they're so [ __ ] weird i think
frenemies are never training they don't
turn to anything i do ever my whole
career
um
i will say like me from two years ago
would look at this and be like i need to
not eat you know what i mean like i i
get it it's still now i'm still like
damn i should just stop eating and i
know that's like so like i'm sorry i
don't trigger anyone but like that's
literally my thoughts like i need to not
eat like
and i was like that i would feel like if
not eating is my my choice of being
skinny
sad i see a girl with a mental illness
that's what i see
but i don't know why youtube's promoting
it dude well i see people are saying oh
she's doing it so people are like
blaming her for turning this into some
kind of like
like fetish it's her body that's like a
fat person being in a bikini you know
what i mean like their body like what do
you know i don't know do you just not
show your body because you have
something
i don't know people are saying there's
no way she's gonna survive that there's
gonna be documentary about her one day
oh well i thought shane already did that
what the hell
obviously it wasn't i don't think it was
like deep i don't think there was like a
deep dive into her i think it was just
like are you okay she said for some
reason some people online just make a
big deal out of things she said that in
the video yes eugene it's because we
care because clearly no one in your life
takes your health seriously
ugh i think it's good comments and
people are holding her accountable
because clearly people in her life
aren't they're not trying to like help
her in any way you know what i mean but
there's only so much you can do as
someone who's also been like on drugs
not that she's on drugs but i don't like
you know people can tell you get help
but you can't but when comments tell you
i'll tell you what comments convince me
more than anybody in my real life to go
get therapy so it's like sometimes when
comments like you're crazy go get there
if you're eating like this
i don't know what her life situation is
like and so i don't either i don't know
much about it didn't she like get help
and gained weight for a minute i think
that is her with a little weight because
she's had purple legs like her legs used
to be purple which is anorexic i don't
think you can lose more weight than this
i think she i think she did get a little
gain a little weight i don't know how
that's possible this is like what people
look like out of the concentration camp
yeah
i don't know what they look like but
they look like this really yeah just
starving
and you would have been like wow skinny
icons yeah no for right well maybe not
with the holocaust but like
with her i i
i look at skinny people and never being
skinny enough like mary kay and ashley i
remember thinking like that's like i
think skinny is vic you cannot like i
used to think you could never be skinny
enough you know what i mean and i still
do i have that warp sense it's like aha
like you can never be too skinny like i
never understood the concept would be
like you're skinny shaving man like you
can't be too skinny like i would love to
be eighty pounds and be too skinny well
in my head i'm saying how i think i'm
like in my head i don't think that i'm
like oh you can never be too skinny
yeah but you're not like skinny
right but what i'm saying is i look at
like
obviously her she's too skinny but like
i'll look at people who they say that
about like oh there's no such thing as
being too skinny
like oh she's getting too skinny i'm
like is that a thing well sometimes well
i there's a thing like ela experience
where people there's like thin shaming
too where ela's like she's just
naturally very thin yeah and so people
always like
she feels sometimes like she's being
thin shamed by people
they like it in a mean way
yeah people is always telling her to eat
more and like oh you're so skinny and
always just making comments about it um
even though it's like you know i saw
someone on tick-tock it was like a
heavier set person that said like the
best thing to do when people were like
i'm like i hate being so skinny is to
tell them that they're not and i'll like
trigger them
i don't know i hate being so scared
you're not you're huge yeah you're
definitely not too skinny i think that's
a horrible idea
i don't know i'm on a weird part of
tick-tock right now um
and i feel bad for her i don't know what
to do i mean it's clearly she's she's
been through a lot of people trying to
help her and i don't know what's like
her immediate uh friends and family
situation like but
yeah do you have anything about awesome
groom about his little get-together in
beverly hills did you see that
um are no thoughts i think he's a douche
the whole thing's such a [ __ ] special
well and also bryce hall made a video
that the dad is not in his life so i was
like we should take it easier on not
that like i guess i knew that i said
yeah yeah so he made a video being like
oh wow what someone made a video not us
but someone else maybe like
making fun of like him not having a dad
he's like okay that's like the job
you're gonna take when i don't have a
dad in my life so like i knew that bryce
hall was fatherless because
that's what that was the vibe i got like
i think he's just a wounded dude where
like he's a douche but like compared to
austin austin is far worse i almost dm
bryce like are you okay because he made
that video and like that's the first
time i've seen bryce be like not so like
tough badass whatever he's a he's a
child you know what i mean i was gonna
be like are you okay because so many
people are like and then i saw that
video where he was like kind of it
looked like there was pain in his eyes
about i don't know maybe i'll just ring
into it but yeah awesome and groom
douche yeah i'm team bryce all the way
on god on god bro
i'm sick of promoting these [ __ ]
boxing matches meanwhile while trailer's
suing me it's like i'm [ __ ] sorry
about talking your dumbass fight and
getting people interested in that at all
so i'm just [ __ ] all these boxing
matches is that oh they're the ones who
sponsored this boxing match no this
isn't trailer trailers trailer's gonna
go bankrupt soon i guess that's good and
i wonder why probably because i stopped
talking about them
when they go bankrupt i'm gonna tap
dance on their [ __ ] grave you watch
you'll be the one bankrupt i'm gonna go
back and forth all day with this lawsuit
you'll be like 10 years into it well i
guaran i'll tell you one thing if we do
go through with this thing it's gonna be
they're gonna be paying my lawyer fees
it's expensive oh yeah it's very
expensive
um so
chad michael murray has had bundy
do you want to keep putting chat yeah
yeah yeah how much time we got dan i
don't i can't see the clock i usually
always see the clock sorry uh about 20
minutes oh you want to do a sample
superhero game who cares everyone's just
pissed chad michael murray's playing ted
bundy because he they say ted bunny was
ugly and they're all these good looking
people zac efron ted ted bunny was
famously like uh he's really not if you
look him up he has those eyebrows that
are close he's not good yeah yeah no but
like he was getting girls he was like
his whole thing was that he wasn't like
he was somewhat attractive yeah he had
game
zac efron was i auditioned for the ted
buddy movie was that girlfriend i didn't
get it wait zach played ted yeah the
upcoming you never know in the netflix
movie you never saw it it's on netflix
now it's pretty good
he's not sick but are you are you stuck
like glorifying serial killers by making
them hot dude everybody's going playing
serial killers every day bro it's like i
don't glorify serial killers i do not
support that at all you don't support
serial murder no
i don't think they can get away with it
these days you know like in the 70s like
like the sharon tate ones they just like
cut her cords and that was it she was
done it's like now what are you gonna
like no no dude now the the detect the
tools available to detectives and saying
like
if they get your dna this is the new
crazy thing they're doing
they can run a dna
like analysis and then identify your
cousins because even if you're not in
the system
and then they'll like work backwards and
find your cousins and they'll figure
like that's how they caught some of
these really cold case serial killers
recently by just the genealogy well even
like there was one guy who killed his
girlfriend and they identified her he
like cut her up all the stuff took her
teeth out everything breast implants
have serial numbers and they identified
her through the breast implants oh the
kitties got you boys yeah try cutting
these things up okay do you wanna play
superhero let's do a little um did you
know i was on a superhero oh no i told
that to before yes how come you've never
seen it i've seen it yeah do you like it
ian can you explain how this works
okay so you're gonna guess the names and
the powers of each i literally got
eliminated for not knowing my super
power well that's why it's gonna be
funny my own superpowers i didn't know
how many what was your super what would
you have no idea it was like miss lime
like they made up powers i didn't know
stanley asked me and i was like i have
no idea he's like you're a lemonade
because you don't know your super hours
i was like all right cool you're like
bye
i was gonna learn a whole back story for
my character that's like so much work
okay wait wait okay oh okay wait who who
is this michael keane no no no what's
the name of the superhero batman and
what's his superpowers uh isn't his
whole thing he doesn't have superpowers
oh i'm impressed i thought you wouldn't
know that
i think i know that i know batman
because i know mike okay i'm starting
easy
thanks this is okay spiderman what's the
superpower
the web thing coming out of his hand
uh that's not all he wa he's flying okay
is that this is that it he just fighting
for strength and stuff
i watched the first movie mcguire and
i'm like i can't get past oh he got bit
by spider there's your superpower
yeah it's an atomic spider i think it's
the stupidest comic book ever i hate
that one i hate that movie the spider
was like radioactive and gave him super
oh my god i hate these things these are
so dumb okay who's this literally no
idea i've seen this person you don't
know who that is no ant-man
with a i don't know and then what what
do you think his superpowers are
is this paul red
it's not oh who is this
it's one of the chris's chris evans
chris
it's it's a captain america okay oh my
god sounds lame i mean just the captain
america alone sounds so stupid and
what's up
saving america george washington are you
did that [ __ ] like what it's so weird
to me he has superhuman strength
as the result of a uh experiment
oh the ptsd of the military
who's this hulk oh
i was just looking at you that's super
good oh baby groot i know him what's his
superpower oh he's a superhero i don't
know
enough superhero powers yeah
arguably
and he's uh uh immortal
he regenerates and he can like grow he's
like a tree i'm giving it away we have
we have the plant at our house so he
brought me home a baby groot and it
grows plants out of its head that's the
superpower in the movie
that's dope we have a little chia pet
version of baby crew that's cute i was
gonna guess that if you would have given
him because i knew it grew plants out of
his head
oh that is um
i do know this one this is x-men right
yes never saw it
i don't like that guy he was on greatest
gentleman i do not think he's a good
singer at all really i like you you
can't be broadway and superhero like
okay calm down just name the hero um i
think he's overrated but i think it's
wolverine hugh jackman huge ass man oh
yeah yeah we did talk about this but not
the name of the actor wolverine is the
name of the hero oh and the super powers
oh my god he grows claws out of his hand
his bones are made of some special
alloy
do you know this or you just have notes
or do you know no i know all these so i
just okay who's this
oh my god
i know all of these yeah you do is it
that i see by the x in the back
is she good or bad good because she's
one of the x-men right and then and then
we cosplay x-men can i be what's her
name
um do you want to be wolverine i'll be
this lady what's her name
i don't know just myself oh avatar
avatar i don't know what's her
superpower she
is like
sexual i don't know i have no idea
what does she do
her name is mystique she's a super
villain and she can shapeshift
i don't know that is she can change she
can look like anyone or anything
hate that i hate that because that's so
that's so not reality jennifer lawrence
oh she's like naked the whole movie oh i
thought it was oh i thought it was like
pamela anderson did that i think for one
movie she was that really mm-hmm okay
who's this you know this one yeah this
is uh thor
and what's his superpower he has a big
hammer
daddy
right isn't his thing oh third's got a
big hammer
i think he's overrated too i don't like
this one either i don't like him he's
the son of mueller he's a god
he's the son of mjolnir is his hammer's
name okay dork
yeah no wait what's his dad's name
odin oh yeah odin odin
he's a god and he commands lightning
i hate it this is where's aquaman
i know him okay who's this
this is like a parody right
yeah it is okay
it's a comedy it's a comedy is this the
deadpool one what's the his name
of the superhero guy okay and what's his
powers
i don't know i have no idea i'm so bad
with these well let's see he's got an
antenna
okay he eats he's ant-man he eats ants
he eats people yes
[Laughter]
he eats and i hate this one this one is
called the tick hankering is gonna
cancel me i mean like she knew it was an
ant by the anteaters i don't know what's
tick it's this one
it's a parody well it's based on an old
cartoon
called the tick i hate i just don't like
superheroes no offense who's this
oh my god
he's in a wheelchair
this is gandhi
did he play gandhi i think that this
city is way off i think he played gandhi
i'm sure you're there ben kingsley is
that his name
you're confusing him with ben kingsley
that is not banking
that would be um this is patrick's story
sir patrick stewart
yeah he's a he's a knight okay and what
is his superpower he's in a wheelchair
he's dressed nicely
um
does he have like a third eye or
something what does that mean like game
of thrones kid in the wheelchair had the
third eye
actually
pretty accurate no it's not yeah it is
well i mean he's a psychic he has
psychic powers right that's the analogy
see the future he just like he can vibe
with everyone these are the kids in high
school i was like
with you actually no one wants to sit
with me but like the nerds would and
they were talking about
yeah you'd be like hey do you want to be
friends no no
okay who's this
iron man obviously what's the superpower
oh god i couldn't tell you the light
things like like i don't know what they
do what are the light up things do
something he has no superpower actually
he's just rich
i just know that vibes david thought he
was iron man okay who's this oh oh
is it boba fett this is boba fett oh
yeah i knew him daniel logan is his name
right i met him at a convention once is
that him that is boba fett okay what's
his superpower i've never seen star wars
i have no idea this is bubba fat for
sure what's a superpower i'm asking you
let's see he's got a shark it looks like
he's got shark fins oh i don't know a
shark mouth on his front i told you i
didn't see her when we went on star wars
you have to guess what his superpower is
that's the game oh my god he's a shark
he has sharks vibes
no this is no that's not that's shark
boy
is it shark boy it kind of yeah it is
shark bite it's not bubble it looks like
boba fett not at all i don't know shark
boy he's a shark
yep wow real creative rob rodriguez we
got a skull on fire
huh oh hellraiser
[Music]
is this nicholas cage probably i think
here it is it is
okay i love a nick cage who cares about
him who's this
not my superman
i like christopher reeves thank you
or george i like the original choice
watching yeah it's not like the most
this biggest irony in the world that
christopher reeves went paralyzed so sad
that's my baseball i won't get on horses
for that well for medieval times i will
but other than that i will knock on a
horse i will not do horses you know
medieval times ghosted us they they like
delete it they're they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're they're they're they're they
they deleted and unfollowed i was like
oh really yeah that's weird they must
have gotten some hate you know when
people are like get hate and they're
like
sorry for trying to promote your
business [ __ ] you reached out to me
yeah by the way someone watched our
podcast reached out to me and then i was
like yo they're like i'll [ __ ] you bye
no can i tell you so okay just a quick
start around like wrapped up but you
know i was obsessed with beetlejuice on
broadway like that was my [ __ ] like that
changed my life i was in such a dark
place when i went to see it and like
changing my life so alex brightman the
guy who plays beetlejuice like followed
me and he's like next time you're at the
show like come backstage and then all of
a sudden he unfollowed me deleted the
tweets because he got an onslaught of
hate like trish is the worst oh and then
then i still got backstage because
another actor in the show reached out to
me like you want to come back so i did
you're like what's up [ __ ]
well i told him to see if he was gonna
like you know be able to like meet me
back there i'm like hey come to the show
i'm gonna be backstage like hope you
enjoyed the show like that was the end
of the dm and i was like oh no he like
goes to me like broke my heart so then
when andrew
bart
not garfield what's his name damn
i don't know his real name i just know
what you call what is it damn it okay so
when the evan hansen tweeted me i was
like redemption broadway doesn't hate me
because like they all ghosted me like
roger bart i think is becoming roger
parker because roger bart was on
broadway that's why he won tony for
young frankenstein the producers so i
think like everyone kind of had a bad
taste in their mouth because they're
like oh trish was like this person or
whatever and then alex brightman got all
the haters or something alex breitman
the guy who would disinvite you from
beetlejuice i didn't no no no no he
seems so nice like i would i think he
just got so much hate and he didn't know
how to deal with it because he was so
like loved and liked no i didn't expose
him i still love him but it like kind of
broke my heart cause i saw him backstage
not taking pictures with the whole cast
except for him like he was like avoiding
me like the flag oh my god uh because i
have pictures with the cast backstage
and they're so nice shout out to adam
dan heiser like all the like everyone uh
presley ryan like they were all so like
all of them were so sweet but it's
something what are we talking about
superman sorry yeah oh christopher
reeves what the [ __ ] jordan is this
that's catwoman her superpower who cares
oh
misogynistic you just gonna go past the
female one
it's obvious she's like she's a cat i
love michelle pfeiffer as catwoman i
used to like is this michelle pfeiffer
no that's halle berry i believe okay
you're on your [ __ ] okay
that's deadpool
yes
is it
actually i see why you said that but
yeah it is
okay what's his superpower i don't know
i never could people like it's so funny
you like it it's not like a superhero
movie then i watch and i was like i
don't get it i don't know his superpower
i have no idea i don't know why ryan
reynolds got to be green lantern and
deadpool that's dumb oh
like why do you get the double dip yeah
it's [ __ ]
wow he's not okay
i mean he's not like that great to be
two characters like you could just pick
one i personally think that
ryan reynolds needs to take a [ __ ]
vacation and stop being and everything
i like
anymore he's in every [ __ ] movie i
don't like him can i tell you why i'd
cancel ryan reynolds because he wore the
fat suit and just friends and i was like
why don't you just have a fact
for that have a fat actor play the role
of the director
i like i like shallow howl no it's not
shallow huh i like shallow houses
can we recreate some scenes from shallow
hair i love shallower fat
i don't need a fat suit i could just be
her i seriously like when she jumps into
the pool i have the same splash as her
i'm not kidding i did a tick tock side
by side of us and i had the exact same
splash as her and it's kind of
everything
i used to like ryan reynolds but until
the point that he's in every movie doing
the same [ __ ] character and i'm just
sick of his like wise guy irreverent
handsome dude i was just like [ __ ]
take a break bro yeah
there's you hulk smash
you should be talk you told me actually
oh let me tell this story on hollywood
boulevard you're like i'm going to go
swoop
whatever the [ __ ] spider-man and you're
like you should go as the hulk could you
imagine if i showed up at the hulk and
you weren't spider-man i would have been
so well i was afraid i'm not going to be
the hulk
i was afraid that you were gonna show up
as like she-hulk and something really
crazy then i would have felt really bad
but you just showed up like no i'm
non-binary hulk i am not either
okay fine not she-hulk what the [ __ ] is
this this is just will smith yeah what
is this
just it's the pursuit of half this is
just some random take care of him will
smith paparazzi pick outside his house
he was
what are you doing on his means i didn't
mean to
see if he's like doing anything um i
don't know this movie what is the answer
to this one
hand on [ __ ] oh my god you are 12 you're
literally 12. that's a [ __ ] hero
hancock hancock
wasn't he in the one is this the one
with margot robbie
no that's suicide squad that's the other
time that he was a superhero well this
outfit looks horrible oh who is that i
mean i know who it is but this show
looks super low budget
is this like those like cw ones i
believe yeah yeah they always are like
dude that looks like a whole that was
like a party city outfit who's this guy
i know this character but i don't know
what's got a lightning bolt do the math
he's like speedrunner he's a speedy guy
because the other guy that plays
speedrunner in a different movie i heard
got canceled because he's like an
[ __ ] to fans his name ezra right ezra
no what's the name of the superhero uh i
don't know take a guess
you got the lightning bolt flash yes you
got it is it flash gordon is it the same
person flash and flash gordon two
separate people yes i always got them
confused you know this one obviously
wonder woman is that gal gadot
okay
superpower
um healing the word world by singing
imagine
do you remember can i ask a serious
question about
wonder woman
she's an amazonian an island of women
they're all lesbians
is that real or is that snl i feel like
i saw an snl no they're all lesbians
they're amazonians what do they not have
sex
maybe they're
trans or something i'm just saying it's
they're they're live there for thousands
of years it's just are you sure yes
that's the back story so i'm saying why
all of a sudden
i am getting it wrong do they have do
they i don't think that that's explicit
in the comics that it's an island well
it was in the movie and also why are you
questioning that when there's like flash
you know what i mean when there's like
people who can shoot spider webs because
well she has like a male love interest
and so i was just like i she's like
you know they
has ela ever cosplayed as her she'd be
good at wonder woman
no because she's very tall oh this one's
obvious oh i've never seen this one
but i've seen it like on i love the 80s
i just can't remember it what is that
one duck boy
who is this
it's howard the duck howard and he has
super powers what is
i think it's kind of a stretch to call
him a superhero i don't know is he a
superhero ian
says he has howard the duck does he fall
in love with a human in the movie
yeah howard [ __ ] a human yeah i hate
these wait did someone [ __ ] howard the
duck in the movie yeah the girl from
back to the future right or is that a
different movie i think so yeah whoa
it's considered one of the worst movies
of all time should we watch it how are
the duck do howard the duck review on
frenemies frenemies vlog how are the
duck reviews i can't believe the duck
[ __ ] a woman
i hate when they did that i hate it when
they like would cross because they did
they have like a intimate sex scene with
her the duck and the woman
who are you asking not me i don't know
well these guys
i don't think i'm pulling it up right
now but you remember that one where brad
pitt had sex with a cartoon
it was like play it cool or cool dude or
something and i was like why or
the rabbit what's the rabbit one roger
rabbit that guy no but that guy said he
went crazy after that movie because he
hallucinated the the people were there
that even after he couldn't get the
hallucinations out of his head so he
still thought he was talking to like
cartoons in real life that can't be real
it's real it just came out actually like
i just saw that on like i don't know
something
but i i don't like when they mix people
with animals like i think there's some
weird like bestiality there i don't like
oh we got the sex scene dan holy [ __ ]
you can watch it well let's watch it
i'll [ __ ] it i wanna i gotta see this
for myself
yo howard the duck intense animal
magnetism
hold up why i say hold up
because i uh okay ew
i don't like it oh it's so crazy here we
go
how howard the duck
is this is the comedy what's happening
here
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
dude the duck is getting oh my god is
that roger burt in the middle i swear
that was him that was so weird i would
oh crazy maybe that looked like him
right that was so weird
all right are we done dan
yeah we're pretty much out of time
anything else trisha oh i'm we're going
to disney this week for theodore's
birthday yeah first time he's never been
i am so pumped do you think he's gonna
get scared sometimes sierra gets a
little scared he gets a little spooked i
don't know like i think the haunted
mansion will for sure spook oh you
cannot take him on that that's so scary
yeah he'll drop like i want to take i
think pirates i don't know i don't know
you might be little for that you have to
do like dumbo
we're gonna do yeah the fantasyland ones
he'll love that like peter pan small
world that you said you've never been on
the world he's gonna love i've been a
small world oh you have been on small
world okay disney fanatic
that's so exciting i'm so excited for
you can we go to universal together for
a vlog
yeah we should okay i like universal
okay the vip tour gives you like a
private trolley like it's can i say it's
better than the disneyland vip because
that vip at universal they let you do
whatever like you want to get off at
jaws go run around jobs we got to
growing around the city i saw you were
back yeah
they never let us do that before though
so i don't know if that's like allowed
the ride for other people doing no they
loved it most contestants everyone's
like treasure everyone's like i was like
i feel like i was part of the attraction
i was like here i am the guy was really
impressed he's like we have the
kardashians here and nobody had that
reaction to them so i felt very he's
blowing you up no he wasn't like that
well maybe you really think
you really think you get recognized more
than the kardashians i want to say
people are more excited to see me than
the kardashians oh stop it i got mobbed
maybe she walked around like this i mean
people spot her like people do not miss
her head mask on they know it's her i
had an anxiety attack so if you're
somebody tried to come up to me and i
was like and the bodyguard was like no i
had a little bit of anxiety attack
because i was the most mob that i've
ever been which i i like love in theory
i love but i got really scared and i had
a panic attack so i kind of like after
we got out of harry potter i literally
started like spitting and i had to like
lay down and then they were like
spitting yeah they had to take me to the
vip area like
but i do love it i do love meeting
people i was like it was overwhelming
but thank you honestly because i'd like
who the [ __ ] cares you are a huge deal
i felt like huge deal i like feeling it
they even let us have our own room in
the restaurant they're like we're gonna
give you guys a private room for 40
people i'm like we don't need a private
room we don't want to have a room before
literally so we had a tip big mom's just
paid for i'm like let me tip it was like
100 so i'm like i'd put another 100 on
there i'm like we need to give them like
500 because we rented this whole room we
didn't ask for it but
i mean they really thought we were a big
deal they're like well when we ate
actually disney they that was such
[ __ ] it was [ __ ] no i'm telling
universe about it
tomorrow okay
but you'll have on disneyland with
theodore i'm very excited for you i'm
excited for theater's birthday i picked
out the presents this year well we
picked them out but i picked them out
they're really really like okay
on the weekend yeah i'll see you on the
weekend i'm so excited giving presents i
love presents i think he's gonna love it
i got him something close i got
something to match me
oh really but it's like it's like a boy
thing it's like a little boy thing okay
he loves prank he'll love anything i'll
wear mine and then we'll be like
matching but trucks for sure
it's around it's like yeah yeah if we
got them cool things like okay all right
we gotta go um
i'm just dying anyway i did this
exercising this morning
we're gonna go walk around west
hollywood and thank you peace and love
we love you all so much because
what love is love love is love is love
is love who said that minimal miranda
and and and watch our vlog okay cause
it's awesome
bye
[Music]
you